Ich habe gerade das Musikproblem gelöst, Harald.
Das ist das Musikproblem gelöst?
Der CD-Player tut es nicht.
Ja, ist ja unglaublich. Ja, Chaosradio startet mit technischem Chaos, wie immer. Ja, willkommen zu Chaosradio 115. Kann ich ja mal ein bisschen einleiten.
Ja, fang mal an, ich versuch mal hier irgendwas in den Griff zu kriegen. Nicht, dass mir das je gelungen wäre, aber...
Ja, naja, das ist ja schön, wenn sich der Moderator und die Techniker kümmert und die Techniker moderieren.
Ja, man lernt eben nicht aus, Herr Welte. Man lernt nicht aus.
Ja, sehr schön. Gut. Ja, Chaosradio 115, das Thema ist die Gesundheitskarte. Die erste Frage wäre natürlich bei dem Thema, was ist denn die Gesundheitskarte?
Im Studio der Harald, der Thomas. Hallo Thomas. Und die Knöpfe, die drücke ich. Ich heiße Holger. Und die erste Frage ist, was ist eigentlich die Gesundheitskarte?
Schön, genau. Da erreichen wir die Frage doch mal an Thomas weiter, unseren Experten.
Ja, also die Gesundheitskarte, die haben wir ja laut Gesetz eigentlich schon seit 1.1. dieses Jahres.
Ich bin auch echt froh, dass ich jeden Morgen ziehe die aus dem Portemonnaie drauf und denke mir, das interessant ist, es hat sie noch niemand.
Es gibt sie sozusagen noch gar nicht. Ist aber vom Gesetz her vorgeschrieben, soll vordergründig erst mal die jetzige versicherten Karte ablösen, aber das täuscht in einem gewissen Sinn. Denn wir reden eigentlich nicht von einer elektronischen Gesundheitskarte, sondern wir reden tatsächlich von einer Gesundheitstelematik. Diese neue Gesundheitskarte soll im Prinzip alle Ärzte, alle Krankenhäuser, alle Apotheken miteinander vernetzen und das heißt diese Gesundheitskarte ist nur die Spitze eines Eisberges, der aus Hunderttausenden von Computern und Netzen besteht und zentralen Einrichtungen, in die dann eben die Gesundheitsdaten der Bürger fließen.
Das heißt, wenn ich die Gesundheitskarte, also was dann wahrscheinlich auch eine Chipkarte sein wird, wenn ich die in der Tasche trage, sind da überhaupt keine Daten drauf, sondern nur meine Personenkennziffer, die dann an irgendein Rechner übermittelt wird und da liegen dann die eigentlichen Daten.
So ist das im Wesentlichen richtig. Diese Chipkarten, im Gegensatz, die bisherige gesunde oder versicherte Karte war eine reine Speicher-Chipkarte. Also ein blödes Stück Silizium. Die neue Gesundheitskarte wird eine sogenannte Smartcard sein, das heißt, da sitzt ein eigener kleiner Prozessor drauf. Aber der Speicher von so einer Chipkarte ist relativ klein. Man redet da von 32 Kilobyte. Man kann auch etwas größere nehmen, aber nicht viel größere. Die sind aber auch gleichsignifikant teurer. Und auf dieser Karte kann man praktisch keine Gesundheitsdaten speichern. Man wird da also mit etwas Glück vielleicht einen Notfalldatensatz unterkriegen, so wie die Personendaten. Und der ganze Rest wird eben im Prinzip über Zeiger auf zentralen Servern gelagert.
Das war's für heute.
Chaosradio 115, die Musik im Hintergrund ist von Kaft oder Mischwerk Potsdam, muss ich sagen, ist CC. Die Gesundheitskarte ist unser Thema. Wer hat denn eigentlich diese Idee gehabt?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Wer wohl die Idee ursprünglich gehabt hat? Also politisch durchgesetzt hat die Idee jedenfalls unsere Gesundheitsministerin Ulla Schmidt, die also zu Beginn der letzten Legislaturperiode eben die Gesundheitskarte durch das Sozialgesetzbuch 5 und durch eine Gesetzgebung in den Spiel gebracht hat. Und man muss sich dann auch vor Augen halten, dass Politiker ja häufig notgedrungen in Zeiträumen von Legislaturperioden denken. Das heißt, sie werden gewählt für einen bestimmten Zeitraum, üblicherweise eben vier Jahre auf Bundesebene. Und man muss ja irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, Handlungsfähigkeit demonstrieren und möglichst schnell irgendwelche Projekte, die man den Staaten zur Umsetzung bringen. Und deswegen wird dann also ein Zeitrahmen vorgegeben, das haben wir bei Tollcollect schon gesehen, dass er nicht einzuhalten ist.
LKW-Maut war das.
Genau.
Aber die funktioniert doch jetzt ganz toll, hab ich gehört. Also dass da jetzt viele Milliarden reinkämen.
Ja, das ist nur die Frage, ob man das nicht viel günstiger hätte haben können, ohne solche Einmalinvestitionen und Tausende.
Ich finde nicht, dass das die Frage ist, sondern die Antwort. Aber gut, gehört nicht hin, geht um die Gesundheitskarte.
Also es ist auch bei der Gesundheitskarte eben so, dass da ein Zeitrahmen vorgesteckt wurde, der eben nicht einzuhalten war. Das ist eigentlich jedem der IT-Großprojekte irgendwie ein bisschen beobachtet. Es ist klar, dass also diese vier Jahre von der Idee bis zur kompletten Einführung einfach eine Illusion sind. Und so sind wir jetzt eben in der obskuren Situation, dass laut Gesetz, wie ab 1.1. dieses Jahres die Gesundheitskarte haben, aber tatsächlich hat sie noch niemand. Also zu der Entstehung oder zu der...
Wie weit sind die denn überhaupt mit der Vorbereitung? Wann werd ich die haben?
Das ist eine ausgesprochen spannende Frage.
Mensch, gute Fragen, spannende Fragen. Ich bin heute in Höchstform.
Ja, die ist wirklich gut. Nur das Problem ist, die können wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die Projektverantwortlichen beantworten. Wenn wir uns einfach den Zeitverlauf anschauen. Die ersten Tests sollten ja 1.1.2005 starten. Still und starr ruht der See. Dann war immer die Rede davon, im ersten Quartal dieses Jahres sollen also die berühmten Zehntausender Tests starten.
Das sind berühmte Zehntausender Tests?
Ja, das sind Testregionen, in denen erstmal 10.000 Patienten, zwei Krankenhäuser, eine gewisse Anzahl Arztpraxen mit dem System arbeiten praktisch. Die wurden dann verschoben ins zweite Quartal. Dann legte man sich fest auf den 30.06. was also so ziemlich der letztmöglichste Termin des zweiten Kartals war. Dann wurden es immer weniger Modellregionen, die zu diesem Zeitpunkt an den Start gehen sollten. Zum Ende zwei und jetzt hat man sich ohne konkrete Festlegung vertagt. Aber man geht wohl insgesamt davon aus, dass vor dem 1.1.2007 überhaupt kein Modellversuch starten wird.
Das fühlt sich nicht so an. Man liest nichts in der Zeitung. Das Chaos Radio ist das einzige Medium, das sich überhaupt mit dem Thema beschäftigt.
Ja, gut. Das Chaos Radio reflektiert ja auch nur einen Bruchteil dessen, was an Themenspektrum innerhalb des CCC zumindest eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit genießt. Die Gesundheitskarte war hier schon, wie alle IT-Grußprojekte, die es gibt, insbesondere in der öffentlichen Hand, ein Thema, das den Chaos Computer Club interessiert hat. Zumal es hier um ein unglaublich komplexes IT-System geht, das auch eine unglaublich komplexe Serie an Sicherheitsmechanismen und möglicherweise Schwachstellen an diesen Sicherheitsmechanismen bearbeitet.
Dadurch, dass es ein IT-Grußprojekt der öffentlichen Hand ist, ist es eigentlich schon prädestiniert dafür, Schwachstellen zu haben und in die Hose zu gehen, zumindest am Anfang. Woher kommt das? Die Maut, die Arbeitsagentur? Allein, ich meine, die haben es noch nicht mal geschafft, eine Webseite mit einer Datenbank dahinter vernünftig zu machen. Woher kommt das? Habt ihr irgendwie als kleinen Ausflug...
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich hab jetzt spontan keine Eingabe dazu. Was mir nur einfällt, ist irgendwie eine Ergänzung der Aufzählung. Da fallen mir noch so Dinge ein wie das Elster-Steuerprojekt, wo du zum Beispiel unter meiner Steuernummer irgendwie Steuererklärungen einreichen kannst.
Ja, kann man auch viel witzigere Sachen machen. Man könnte natürlich, die Steuernummern passieren ja nach einem festen Schema. Es wäre also ohne Weiteres möglich, für alle Bundesbürger Steuererklärungen einzureichen. Und das ist halt insofern interessant. Wir könnten jetzt ihm schaden, wenn wir seine Steuernummer hätten. Okay.
Aber meine steht auf meinen Rechnungen.
Ja, das ist dann schon unklug.
Ich bin ja verpflichtet, die da drauf zu schreiben.
Ja, man kann sich auch eine Umsatzsteuer-ID holen. Aber ich bin nicht Umsatzsteuer... Der spannende Punkt ist ja einfach der folgende. Man kann damit die Infrastruktur der Steuerbehörden lahmlegen, wenn die nämlich klären müssen, welche von den 20 Steuererklärungen von welchem Bürger die richtige ist.
Ja, gut. Nichtsdestotrotz wollen wir über die Gesundheit gerade sprechen heute. Aber wir sehen, also irgendwie Gesundheitsprojekte der öffentlichen Hand bieten dem schamelosen Zynismus offensichtlich hinreichend Futter.
Wobei wir noch nicht über die Gründe geredet haben. Und das ist eben denke ich der für die Gesundheitskarte oder für den Zynismus? Für die für die extremen, für die extremen Erlebnisse, die wir mit diesen Leuchttürmen von Public Private Partnerships und öffentlichen IT Projekten haben. Und da kann man einfach nur sagen, die Politik ist ja sozusagen neu in dem Feld, der Großprojekte in der Industrie hat man sich schon hinreichend die Finger verbrannt. Und in Amerika sagt man immer wieder, jeden Morgen steht ein Dummer auf, man muss ihn nur finden. Es scheint so, als ob die Leute, die nach dieser Art und Weise IT Projekte machen, nachdem sie in der Industrie nicht mehr so viele Leute finden, die keine Erfahrungen haben, ein neues Betätigungsfeld gefunden haben. Das wäre zumindest mal so meine persönliche Meinung zum Thema.
Man muss versuchen, mit politischen Entscheidern klarzumachen, dass man Menschen fragen kann, die sich mit was auskennen.
Naja, wir hatten das vorhin in der Vorbesprechung zur Sendung schon. Es gibt halt Leute, die immer irgendwie Versprechungen, positive Versprechungen irgendwie daher erzählen. Was sind das für Segnungen, die jetzt in diesem Fall das Land bringen soll. Vielleicht bleiben wir doch einfach mal gleich bei dem Aufhänger. Genau, den Soll-Segnungen sozusagen.
Genau, die Soll-Segnungen.
Also das ist ein schönes Stichwort. Wir können jetzt nämlich einfach mal den Abgleich zwischen Versprechern, also zwischen Versprechen und Versprechern machen. Es wird also gesagt, dass die elektronische Gesundheitskarte also Qualität, Wirtschaftlichkeit und Transparenz verbessern, sowie weniger Bürokratie für Patienten, Ärzte und Kassen bringen. Das ist ein Originalzitat. Ulla Schmidt. Und das soll im Wesentlichen erreicht werden mit den Anwendungen der Gesundheitskarte.
Entschuldige, Qualitätsverbesserung, das ist doch wieder so eine Null-Aussage, oder? Ich meine, welche Qualität wird denn da?
Ja, da wollten wir jetzt gerade hinkommen. Wir haben zwei Pflichtanwendungen. Die eine Pflichtanwendung ist die Ausweisfunktion. Das ist im Wesentlichen nichts anderes, als die jetzige versicherten Karte, Name, Anschrift, Geschlecht, Geburtsdatum, Kasse. Der nächste Punkt wird dann schon auch sicherheitstechnisch etwas heikler, aber wir beleuchten erstmal ein bisschen medizinisch das Ganze, ist das E-Rezept. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin kein Mediziner. Ich habe aber sehr viel mit Medizinern geredet, also wirklich mit Hunderten, und habe auch vor Medizinern über das Problem berichtet, sodass ich also, und da bin ich immer bestätigt worden, jetzt auch in diesen medizinischen Einschätzungen. Und man erhofft sich unter anderem von diesem elektronischen Rezept, beispielsweise automatisierte Verträglichkeitsprüfungen. Das ist also so eines dieser Versprechen, was ja überall, ja sicher, wenn das funktionieren würde, wäre das ganz hervorragend. Es gibt da nun ein klitzekleines Problem. Zumindest mal aus Sicht der Mediziner. Das Problem ist, ich weiß nicht, wie ist die Compliance? Die Compliance des Patienten. Das heißt, nimmt er seine Medikamente.
Ach so, wie gut spielt er mit?
Genau. Das kann sogar sein, dass er ein Medikament zurecht absetzt. Weil zum Beispiel im Beipackzettel steht, wenn Sie diese Nebenwirkung beobachten, setzen Sie sie sofort ab. Das ist also der eine Punkt. Der hat dieses Rezept zwar vor zwei Wochen gekriegt, aber nimmt er das jetzt noch? Ich weiß ja auch nicht, in welcher Dosierung er es gekriegt hat. Ich weiß also gar nicht, wie lange er es nimmt. Dann gibt es durchaus relevante, nicht verschreibungspflichtige Wirkstoffe. Zum Beispiel Kaffee, Milch, Krebsfrutsaft, die mit bestimmten Medikamenten wechselwirken. Vitaminpräparate, Vitamin K und Makoma ist einfach keine sehr günstige Kombination, weil das Vitamin K das Makoma neutralisiert.
Was ist Makoma?
Das ist ein Blutverdünnungsmedikament. Es hebt die Blutgerinnung auf. Mit Vitamin K kann man das wieder korrigieren. Dann setzt die Blutgerinnung wieder ein. Man gibt dieses Medikament nur bei ziemlich gravierenden Zuständen. Dann gibt es rezeptfreie Medikamente. Und schließlich auch noch Medikamente aus dem Familienfundus, aus dem Internet oder irgendwelche illegalen Wirkstoffe. Die zwar der Arzt wissen muss und die im momentanen, geschützten Vertrauensraum zwischen Arzt und Patient der Patient auch kommunizieren kann. Der könnte also sagen, Herr Doktor, wenn Sie jetzt sagen, ich sollte da keine Cannabis-Produkte zu dem Medikament nehmen, also so gelegentlich, dann sagt der Arzt, dann gebe ich Ihnen was anderes. Und wir sehen in Österreich, die sind schon etwas weiter, da hat die Einführung der eCard also schon zu einem deutlich verschlechterten Vertrauensverhältnis zwischen Arzt und Patient geführt, berichten zumindest die österreichischen Ärzte. Das heißt also alleine schon dieses Versprechen, wir kriegen hier eine automatisierte Wechselwirkungsprüfung hin. Das geht dann bis zu Ideen, wie die Nachtapotheke ist nicht mehr mit einem Menschen besetzt, das kann jetzt ein Roboter machen. Es hat ja auch in Deutschland noch nie eine Fehlbestückung von Automaten gegeben. Kann gar nichts passieren.
In Deutschland doch nicht.
Eben. Hat in Deutschland noch nicht Stromausfälle gegeben.
Die anderen, die können das alle nicht, wir kriegen das hin.
Genau. Und man sieht also schon, dass diese Versprechen in dieser Form wahrscheinlich nicht haltbar sind. Und gerade das E-Rezept ist ohnehin recht prickelnd. Um ein E-Rezept auszustellen, muss der Arzt eine sogenannte elektronische Signatur leisten. Bisher hat er eine Signatur, also eine Unterschrift per Hand geleistet. Jetzt muss er das elektronisch machen. Und da weiß man jetzt einfach aus der letzten Messe, wo sowas vorgestellt wurde, so ein typisches Rezept mit drei Verordnungen braucht 70 Sekunden. Davon hat eine durchschnittliche Praxis 100 pro Tag. Das macht 7000 Sekunden, macht etwa 2 Stunden Aufwand. Statt bisher unter Zeichen eines Rezepts, das hat man also gemessen, brauchen die Ärzte etwa 2, 25 Sekunden für. Verglichen sozusagen 225 Sekunden gegen 7000, das macht etwa 2 Stunden mehr Aufwand, hier Praxis. Und wenn man mal so eine Landarztpraxis nimmt, oder eine Praxis, wo beispielsweise ein Altenheim in der Nähe ist...
Da muss doch die ganze Zeit irgendein Gerät mitschleppen, der arme Arzt. Das ist wie beim Pizza-Jungen, der mit EC-Karte kassiert.
Genau.
Was für ein Vergleich.
Selbst das finde ich schon völlig absurd, was du zum Lesegerät angetanzt hast.
Ja, der wird wahrscheinlich auch einen Rechner mitschleppen müssen. Er wird sogar, das ist das Schönste, es soll eine Online-Prüfung stattfinden der Ausweise.
Muss ja, ich meine, es muss ja auch, sonst kann ich ja die Arzt-Signatur fälschen und deck mich mit irgendwie...
Nein, nein, nein, das geht nicht so leicht, die Arzt-Signatur zu fälschen. Aber es soll eine Online-Prüfung der Patientenausweise stattfinden. Ob der noch bei der Versicherung versichert ist und dergleichen. Schlecht, wenn man in einem Funkloch sitzt.
Genau, also ich meine, technisch ist das durchaus realisierbar mit irgendwie GPS und Handys und so weiter. Kostet halt alles eine Stange Geld. Aber wenn man sich dann die tatsächliche Abdeckung irgendwie anschaut, ich bin heute erst wieder irgendwie quer durch Deutschland zweimal mit dem ICE gefahren und ich würde sagen, irgendwie so in 30 Prozent der Zeit hatte ich irgendwie eine Verbindung zum Datennetz und die restlichen 70 Prozent war eben die Verbindung weg. Dann kann man sich irgendwie ausmalen, wie gut dann sowas funktionieren wird. Im Übrigen kann man da auch wieder schön über die Grenze zu unseren südlichen Nachbarn nach Österreich blicken. Die hatten ja auch nur sehr diffuse Vorstellungen davon, wie sie denn sowas wie Hausbesuche überhaupt in ihr System hineinpressen. Das heißt, man hat also ein Gesundheitskartensystem dort eingeführt. Das kann man jetzt nicht eins zu eins vergleichen mit dem, was in Deutschland kommen wird. Aber da hat man dann gesagt, na ja, da müsste man dann irgendwie mobile Endgeräte haben. Bis heute hat, glaube ich, noch niemand so ein Endgerät gesehen. Und das wird mit irgendeinem Ersatzverfahren auf Papier und dann wird es nacherfahrt.
Auf Papier mit Unterschrift und Stempel.
Logisch.
Das ist ohnehin der Witz. Denn in den Sicherheitsanforderungen, man hat also dann irgendwann mal erkannt, Technik kann ausfallen.
Ja, aber nicht in Deutschland.
Ja, aber trotzdem, also man hat eingesehen, Technik kann ausfallen. Also es hat ja dann doch auch in den letzten, also 2004, 2005 hat es ja doch zwei etwas spektakuläre Stromausfälle gegeben. In einem saß ich mittendrin, das war also relativ spannend. Außerdem...
Ein Glück brauchtest du keine Medikamente.
Und deswegen ist vorgesehen, dass also für den Technikausfall muss also für alle Prozesse ein, wie das so schön im Amtsdeutsch heißt, paralleler, papiergestützter Prozess existieren.
Das heißt...
Nein, nein, das darfst ruhig du sagen.
Das heißt, wir bekommen nicht ein neues System, das alles viel toller macht, sondern wir bekommen ein zusätzliches System.
Korrekt.
Und das Alte bleibt bestehen.
Richtig erkannt. Das heißt, es wird in Übergangszeit...
Da stell ich mir jetzt wirklich mal die Frage, oder ich stell sie euch mal, ich weiß ja, ihr habt ja vielleicht auch noch mal... Hat Ulla Schmidt noch alle Tassen? Also begreift die das nicht besser? Begreift unsere Gesundheitsministerin das nicht? Oder will sie nicht? Das sieht doch ein Blinder mit einem Krückstock, dass da der Wurm drin ist. Da muss der Frau doch mal irgendjemand gesagt haben.
Naja, so leicht ist es dann auch wieder nicht.
Ich finde das so leicht. Also ich finde, dass da der Wurm drin ist.
Vielleicht gibt es auch Paralleluniversen.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Und in ihrem Universum gelten diese Einwände nicht. Das kann ja sein.
Kommt ja auch aus Aachen.
Ja, und war da wohl auch... Nein, das vertiefen wir jetzt nicht. Aber in der Wikipedia gibt es da ein paar interessante Einträge zu. Also das kann man durch erstmal...
Zu Gesundheitskarte oder zu...
Zu beiden.
Mensch, was in der Wikipedia alles steht.
Ja, das ist nicht toll, ne?
Gibt es denn dann noch mal irgendwo eine Schnittstelle, die das papiergestützte ausfallsichere System mit dem elektronischen System noch mal abgleicht? Weil irgendwann muss ich diese Daten doch auch mal zusammenführen. Das heißt, jeder, der Medikamente während des Stromausfalls bekommen hat, hat die bekommen, ohne dass die in seiner digitalen Patientenakte überhaupt nur auftauchen.
Exakt. Es kommt ja auch nicht vor.
In Deutschland kommt es ja nicht vor.
Nein, ich meine, so dieser Fallback aufs Papier, ich meine, der wird ja nur dann funktionieren, also der wird ja nur dann passieren, wenn irgendwie der Weltuntergang uns bevorsteht. Also ich meine, für mich klingen diese ganzen Versprechungen immer so ein bisschen wie das Papierlose Büro.
Stimmt, da war auch mal was.
Genau.
Ich druck's mal aus.
Chaosradio 115, die Gesundheitskarte ist unser Thema. Bevor wir euch mit allen Informationen über die Gesundheitskarte versorgen, überlegt euch doch mal, was für Informationen ihr über die Gesundheitskarte denn schon habt und woher ihr sie habt. Nach den Nachrichten wollen wir mit euch drüber reden unter 0331 77 97 110.
Band läuft, los geht's.
Lieber Hörer oder lieber Hörerin, wir laden sie herzlich ein, bei der Internationalen Funkausstellung mit Fritz dabei zu sein. Und zwar in der Fritz Ditsch Ditschet it Fritz Ditschet Fritz Digital Music Lounge. Ja, in dieser Digital Music Lounge, dem Forum für junge Leute, technikorientierte und musikbegeisterte IFA-Besucher. So? Und Fritz ist auch dabei?
Fritz auf der internationalen Funkausstellung IFA Vom 1. bis 6. September in der Fritz Digital In der Fritz Ditsch Ditsch Ditsch Digital Music Lounge In der Fritz Digital Music Lounge Halle 2.1 auf dem Messegelände Berlin Digitale Musikwelten und im Radio Fritz vom RBB 1.30.11 Fritz Info Nachrichten mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich UNO Generalsekretär Anan hat das bedauern Israels über die Tötung von vier Blauhemdsoldaten im Süd Libanon angenommen.
Er habe dem israelischen Ministerpräsidenten Olmert eine gemeinsame Untersuchung vorgeschlagen, sagte Anan nach einem Telefonat mit Olmert. Bei dem Luftangriff im Libanon waren gestern Abend vier UN-Soldaten getötet worden. Die Teilnehmer der internationalen Libanon-Konferenz in Rom haben von Israel und der Hezbollah schnellstmöglich eine Waffenruhe gefordert. Außerdem soll eine internationale Truppe unter UN-Mandat stationiert werden. An der Konferenz nahmen Vertreter von 20 Staaten und internationalen Organisationen teil, darunter auch arabischen Staaten. Die Verhandlungen im Tarifstreit der kommunalen Klinik Ärzte sind nach fünfwochiger Dauer festgefahren. Der Vorsitzende des Marburger Bundes Montgomery sagte in Ingolstadt, die Arbeitgeber seien weder bereit, ein neues Angebot vorzulegen, noch hätten sie sich auf eine Schlichtung eingelassen. Laut Marburger Bund haben heute 15.000 Ärzte an kommunalen Krankenhäusern gestreikt. Hinter Mailand ist im Zuge des Fußballskandals in Italien offiziell zum Meister 2006 erklärt worden. Dies gab der italienische Fußballverband am Abend bekannt. Zuvor waren Juventus Turin wegen der Liga-Manipulation die Titel 2005 und 2006 aberkannt worden. Und noch zwei Testspielergebnisse. Energie Cottbus hat gegen Atletico Madrid 1 zu 1 unentschieden gespielt. Hertha BSC wiederum hat bei dem FC St. Pauli 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Nacht bleibt trocken. Temperaturen sacken auf 20 bis 15 Grad. Morgen dann wieder viel Sonne und maximal 36 Grad. Achtung wegen der Hitze ist im Moment höchste Waldbrandgefahr. Der Verkehr auf Ritz A10, westlicher Berliner Ring, Dreieck Haftland Richtung Dreieck Werder. Vorsicht bitte zwischen Falkensee und Brieselang. Hier ist ein LKW liegen geblieben, der steht unbeleuchtet auf der rechten Fahrspur. Und A111, der Autobahnzubringer Hamburg, statt einwärts allerdings Richtung Charlottenburg. Zwischen Weitmannslusterdamm, Hermsdorferdamm und Kurt Schumacherdamm ist die A111 heute Nacht wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Ansonsten nichts Aktuelles. Gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Gerald Kötter. Einrich drei Minuten nach halb elf jetzt.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Chaosradio 115 mit der Gesundheitskarte als Thema und jetzt seid ihr eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110.
Ja und ich wollte ja noch ergänzigen.
Lass mich doch mal meinen Satz noch zu Ende sagen.
Nein, das war jetzt ganz dringend, weil das in Bezug zu den Nachrichten bzw. zu dem Jingle vor den Nachrichten war. Da fiel mir doch ein Fritz Fischt Frische Digits oder wie war das?
Digits? Digits waren diese Dinger...
Na, in Anlehnung an dieses Digit-Dings da.
Digit Music Lounge.
Genau.
Frische Fischers Fitts. Jetzt hab ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Ich wollte so was sagen wie, während der Nachrichten, da braucht ihr natürlich nicht anzurufen, denn der Einbeinige, der immer an der Hotline sitzt, der ist gleichzeitig auch derjenige, der die Nachrichten hier vorliest. Also während der Nachrichten nicht. Teasing nennt das der Radiofachmann. 0331 77 97 110, die Nummer der Fritz Hotline. Die Frage lautete?
Die Frage lautete? Was ihr denn bisher über die Gesundheitskarte wisst und woher ihr das denn wisst. Das ist die Frage, die wir im Moment haben. Ansonsten wollte ich noch sagen, das nennt man Personalunion.
Personalunion? Was jetzt? Ach so, dass der Einbeinige auch der Nachrichtensprecher ist. Ja gut, ich meine, irgendwie müssen wir das ja, die üppigen Gehälter der festangestellten Redakteur.
Also wie soll ich sagen, wir sind ja jetzt im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk, aber ich könnte ja jetzt sagen, na ja, wenn dann am 1.1.
Moment, aber Internet ist doch gar nicht Rundfunk.
Tja, da streiten sich die Müter auf, seh ich dich.
Können wir jetzt bitte über irgendetwas anderes reden? Zum Beispiel, wie wär's denn mit...
Gesundheitskarte?
Gesundheitskarte? Was war das für eine Stimme?
Ja, hatten wir da nicht einen anderen Ruf mittlerweile, oder?
Es klingelt noch. Ne, noch ist keiner drin, ne.
Aha, gut, also es weiß niemand etwas über die Gesundheitskarte.
Ne, die Gesundheitskarte ist quasi inexistent.
Das bestätigt uns ja in dem Ansinnen eine Sendung über deren Aufklärung nach unserem Sichtpunktenzimmer.
Der war aber auch irgendwas mit dem Satz nicht in Ordnung, ne?
Ja, dieser Satz kein Verb, ich weiß.
Dieser auch nicht.
Das macht aber nichts, wir haben ja auch IT-Projekte ohne Sinn, also insofern.
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Kommen wir doch mal wieder zurück. Was haben wir denn noch so für Segnungen?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Versprechungen, das war doch eigentlich ganz hübsch.
Ja, also eigentlich meine Lieblingsversprechung ist...
Jetzt haben wir einen Anrufer. Oh, schade. Hallo Christian.
Grüß euch, ich finde es ja schön, dass ihr euch so erfreut über die technischen Errungenschaften.
Nein, eigentlich amüsieren wir uns auf andere Leute Kosten.
Ist auch gut.
Danke für die Gebühren.
Nee, aber ist ja ein interessanter Ansatz, den jeder betrachtet. Und diese Karten, diese technischen Fortschritte, die dich ja bringen soll, oder wie du eben herzhaft gelacht hast, dass das Papier nebenbei doch noch benötigt wird. Ihr kenne ja dann den Impuls in eure, ja, in euer humorvollen Abend. Seid ihr noch da?
Ja, wir machen ganz gespannt.
Achso, das ist eine ganz alte Geschichte. Die ist 90 Jahre nach Christus aufgeschrieben worden. Da hättet uns diese technische Verarbeitung, dass die Menschen mit diesen elektronischen, verarbeitenden Geräten, die da jetzt gibt, Karten, Telefonkarten, Versicherungskarten etc. Da jetzt in der Offenbarung 13 in der Bibel steht, dass die Leute sich ein Malzeichen an ihre rechte Hand und an ihre Stirn machen müssen. Und wer diese Zahl nicht hat, kann weder kaufen, noch Krankenkassen, Sachen erledigen. Und da wollte ich mal drauf hinweisen.
Was in der Bibel steht, kann weder kaufen, noch Krankenkassen, Sachen erledigen? Mensch, du was denn mit deiner Spur.
Das heißt, man kann also, du wirst ja feststellen, nachher ja nicht mehr zum Arzt gehen, wenn man diese Karten, die Chipkarten, Versicherungskarten, Telefonkarten, wenn du jetzt ja telefonieren willst, hast du ja schon trauer, wenn du keine Telefonkarte bei hast.
Die ist ja wenigstens noch anonym.
Achso, naja, das ist wohl wahr. Aber das geht ja um diese absolute Kontrolle, den Menschen dort gläsern zu machen. Und ich finde, dass jeder so lacht, ist schon, freut mich so ein Stück weit mit, dass ihr das so ein bisschen, ja.
Na ja, also im Grunde ist es jetzt Kritik daran, dass wir uns darüber lustig machen, Christian?
Nein, im echten Teil. Ich freu mich ja darüber, wenn Menschen da noch ein Stück weit Humor entwickeln können. Aber wie ihr sagt, es läuft eben darauf hinaus, dass es wirklich so kommen wird. Und das wird sich auch so für mich, wie ich es erlebe, erfüllen. Ich darf das seit 20 Jahren beobachten. Rasant nimmt es zu. Meine Krankenkassenkarten wird ständig erneuert.
Die kriegen alle Publikationen von der AOK, kann ich gar nicht sagen. Der entscheidende Punkt ist, die neue Karte, die kommen wird, ist was völlig anderes. Diese neue Karte wird tatsächlich eben genau den kläsernen Patienten bringen. Das heißt, die Rezepte, bisher ist es so, die Krankenkasse weiß nicht, welches Rezept du verschrieben bekommst. Das weiß der Arzt, das weiß der Apotheker, das weiß die ärztliche Abrechnungsstelle, das weiß die Apotheker-Abrechnungsstelle, die übrigens witzigerweise im Strafgesetzbuch Paragraf 203 alle unter die ärztliche Schweigepflicht fallen. Die einzige Institution, auch die privaten Krankenversicherungen, die sowas ja auch zu sehen bekommen, die fallen auch unter die ärztliche Schweigepflicht, also auch alle Mitarbeiter. Wer da nicht drin steht, wer da nicht drunter fällt, ist witzigerweise die gesetzlichen Krankenkassen.
Aber die werden doch sowieso jetzt gerade abgeschafft, oder nicht?
Ja, vielleicht hat man das damals schon gesehen. Jetzt kommt aber der entscheidende Punkt. Mit dem elektronischen Rezept wird sich das ändern. Und wenn ich die Rezeptdaten von jemandem habe, also machen wir es einfach für den medizinischen Laien, was könnte jemand haben, der Insulin verschrieben bekommt? So, und jetzt, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel weiß, jemand hat Diabetes.
Ja, dann stelle ich die nicht mehr ein.
Genau, und nicht nur ihn nicht ein. Ich stelle auch seine Kinder nicht mehr ein. Denn ich weiß, dass die Kinder auch eine erhöhte Wahrscheinlichkeit haben, Diabetes zu kriegen. Diese Kinder werden auch keine private Krankenversicherung mehr kriegen, wenn diese Daten zugänglich sind. Die werden keine Lebensversicherung, die werden keine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung mehr kriegen.
Darum finde ich euer Humor so erquicken, dass diese Schlinge, die da gelebt ist, und die sich wirklich vor, sag ich mal, seit 20 Jahren, darf ich das beobachten, vor meinen Augen, ob das Fahrkartenautomaten sind, an den U-Bahn-Höfen oder sonst dergleichen. Diese elektronische Schlinge, sag ich mal, so erlebe ich das, zieht sich immer mehr zu, wie du sagst, dass diese biometrischen Geschichten bis ins dritte, vierte Glied weiter fortgefahren wird, und zu sagen, du hast wahrscheinlich das, was dein Alter hatte. Ich nehme mal diese Gläsernheit, und da habe ich die Brücke geschlagen, zu dem ist zwar eine Bibel, ich weiß, aber da steht das nun mal drin.
Man mag ja die Bibel für Mumpitz halten oder nicht. Was ich wirklich faszinierend finde, ist, dass irgendwann irgendjemand mal so viel Weitsicht besessen hat, die Marktwirtschaft zu Ende zu denken.
Aber stell dir mal vor, an die rechte Hand, es soll ja annehmen, an die rechte Hand ein Malzeichen, oder an die Stirn. Wenn du diese Zahl nicht hast, und übrigens auf so einem roten Rezept, das ist auch die Zahl 666, musst du mal dir so ein Rezept angucken. Es ist ein Hammer, was da stattfindet. Und darum habe ich genug gehabt, euch mal anzurufen, zu sagen, die Brücke zu schlagen, dass diese in der offenbaren 13 vor 90 nach Christus umgeschrieben ist, also fast 2000 Jahre her. Und denn diese Sendung mit diesem Aufruf, nimm mal dran teil. Und was du sagst, kann ja einteils gut sein, denn zu sagen Mensch, die Verwaltung, kranke Insulinverteilung, Medikamentenverteilung, soziale Rechtigkeit, das mag ja alles ganz nett sein. Aber der Krux an der Sache ist eben das, was du gesagt hast, dass man es eben genauso negativ verwenden kann. Und da fallen mir einige Regimes ein.
Ja, die gab es auch auf unserem Boden.
Genau, schon in der Sache.
Christian, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf, Christian.
Ja, ich bedanke mich auch und wünsche euch alles Gute.
Das ist schon irre, ne? Also einfach mal 2000 Jahre in die Zukunft denken können. So viel Weitblick hätte ich von den Leuten gar nicht erwartet. 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Rufnummer. Es geht um die Gesundheitskarte bzw. den Ratten-Schwanz, der da hinten dranhängt. Interessanter Anrufer, Sebastian. Hallo Sebastian. Hallo. Du bist 13 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Und du weißt mit der Gesundheitskarte was anzufangen?
Na ja, ich hab davon gehört.
Was denn?
Also von meiner Mutter, die Ärztin ist. Und na ja, also zukünftig wird es praktisch so sein, dass alle Kosten, die dadurch entstehen, anteilig auf die Ärzte abgewälzt werden.
Super.
Aus eigener Tasche.
Ja, ich darf trösten, es bleibt auch ein bisschen was an den Patienten hängen aller Voraussicht nach.
Was ja dann auch gleichzeitig wieder auf die Ärzte abgewälzt wird, weil dann geht der Patient eben einmal weniger hin.
Oder das Honorar wird gekürzt.
Wie steht denn deine Mutter zu dieser ganzen Aktion?
Sie wills auch nicht. Also zu viel Bürokratie, der entsteht. Also eben durch diese verlängerten Siegnaturzeiten für die Rezepte. Also ist nicht wirklich gut. Und dass auch praktisch diese Karte ein Gegenstück, also praktisch ein Teil ist von einer Identifizierung. Also dass es praktisch ein Schlüssel ist, der an den Schloss gesteckt wird.
Und zwar ein eindeutiger Schlüssel für jeden einzelnen Bürger.
Genau, genau.
Ist auch so wieder so was, was die Stasi sich nie getraut hätte.
Da müssen wir nachher noch mal auf die Stasi zurückkommen, weil man hat sich bei der Stasi bedient an einer interessanten Stelle. Aber jetzt wollen wir den Sebastian nicht unterbrechen.
Ja, also ich hab eigentlich noch eine Frage. Und zwar, ach nee, ich wollte noch was sagen. Und zwar, das Ganze wird dann ja praktisch in einem Intranet enden. Und da werden auch, ja, also, ja.
Du meinst ja in einem bundesweiten Intranet dann letztlich.
Genau, genau, genau, ja. Im bundesweiten Intranet. Und ich hab, also meine Mutter hat aus dem Stimmen gehört, dass es praktisch Leute gibt, vereinzelt, die zum Ende praktisch gedacht haben, dass das Ganze in den EU-Mitgliedstaaten eingeführt werden soll. EU-weit.
Na ja, dazu vielleicht irgendwie als Anmerkung, wir hatten ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen, dass in Österreich durchaus eine Gesundheitskarte, die sogar die iCard dort eingeführt, eine andere Schwerpunkt hat als das, was in Deutschland passiert. Es gibt auch Gesundheitskartenprojekte in allen möglichen anderen Ländern. Wenn wir dann später zu den von uns vermuteten oder nahegelegten echten Beweggründen kommen, dann geht es ja bei solchen IT-Großprojekten ähnlich wie bei Tolkolekt ja auch darum, dass man das ja auch exportieren möchte. Dass man das in Deutschland dann möglichst schnell umsetzen will, damit man den anderen demonstrieren kann. Man kann sowas irgendwie realisieren und dann dieses Know-how und die Technologie zu verkaufen ins Ausland. Das Einzige, was tatsächlich meiner Erkenntnis nach irgendwie EU-weit einheitlich eingeführt wird, ist dieser Heilberufsausweis, die Health Professional Card. Das ist also auch eine Chip-Karte, aber eben nicht für den Versicherten, sondern für den Arzt oder das Pflegepersonal.
Sebastian, wenn deine Mutter dagegen ist, gegen die Einführung dieser Gesundheitskarte, unternimmt sie irgendwas dagegen, redet sie mit Patienten darüber und sagt, hier sprechen sie mal mit ihrem Abgeordneten?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Warum nicht?
Ach ja, das ist eine längere Geschichte. Aber bei uns in der Umgebung fallen jetzt nach und nach Ärzte aus, weil die praktisch alle Renten erreicht sind. Und da ist jetzt praktisch so, an manchen Tagen, zum Quartalsanfang, die Flange so lang, dass die bis raus auf die Straße stehen. Was? Ja, wir haben jetzt, wenn ich mal überlege, in den nahegelegenen drei Dörfern, also wir leben in einer ziemlich ländlichen Gegend, bei Elsterwerder, so in der Drehe, also nicht viel los haben wir, wenn ich mal schätze, fünf Ärzte.
Und wie viel Scheine pro Arzt?
Oh, oh, keine Ahnung. Zu viel.
Ja, das klingt nach mehr als 2000 oder sowas.
Wenn die Schlangen bis raus auf die Straße stehen.
Aber nur jetzt zum Quartalsanfang.
Naja, aber das ist ja typisch. Alle Leute, die eine sogenannte Dauermedikation kriegen, kriegen ja typischerweise für längere Zeiträume häufig fürs Quartal die Medikamente. Genau.
Und bekommen dann eben die 10 Euro Quittung.
Und ich hab also beispielsweise Zahlen gehört von Ärzten, die sagen, also in so einer Quartalanfangssituation, da hat man mal locker 300 Rezepte, die an einem Morgen auszustellen sind.
So extrem war es bei uns nicht. Normalerweise haben wir an einem Tag ungefähr, als wir noch einen zweiten Arzt im Dorf hatten, ungefähr 60 bis 50 Patienten am Tag.
Trotzdem der totale Wahnsinn.
Ja, normalerweise. Und seit eben der Arzt weg ist zu totales Anfang, waren es innerhalb von drei Tagen knapp 300 Patienten.
Da bleibt dann nicht mehr viel Zeit für Aufklärungsarbeit. Sebastian, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank und gute Nacht. Und meine Gegenstimme haben wir auch noch natürlich.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, werden ja auf dieser Karte dann auch sämtliche schon passierten Behandlungen gespeichert, oder?
Nein, das ist technisch einfach nicht möglich. Die Cachta hat nur 32 Kilobyte an Speicher. Da würde man noch nicht mal einen einzigen Arztbrief darauf unterbringen.
Der Hintergrund ist einfach der, ich habe vor ein paar Jahren mit meiner Frau mal eine dreizeitig blöde Geschichte durchmachen müssen. Und wir sind von drei Ärzten senden müssen, weil der eine hat immer nicht gewusst. Und die hat dann eine relativ uncoolen Untersuchung dreimal die gleiche über sich ergehen lassen müssen. Und da habe ich gesagt, das müsste doch auf dieser bescheuerten Chipkarte doch mal, müssen doch diese Daten gespeichert werden können, dass nicht jeder das gleiche noch mal macht. Weil es war echt unangenehm.
Na, sie werden dann doch zentral gespeichert, aber dann irgendwo oder nicht?
Ja, also wir haben eben geredet, es gibt zwei Pflichtanwendungen. Es gibt natürlich auch noch sogenannte freiwillige Anwendungen. Dazu wird irgendwann mal eine elektronische Patientenakte gehören. Da geht aber noch eine ganze Weile ins Land, bis wir soweit sind.
Vielleicht kann man das an der Stelle auch erwähnen. Da wird offiziell davon gesprochen, dass man irgendwie 2012 ins Auge fasst für diese optionale elektronische Patientenakte. Und wir wissen ja, wie das mit den Prognosen für irgendwelche Realisierungszeiträume ist.
Was waren die Pflichtanwendungen?
Die Pflichtanwendungen waren Ausweis und E-Rezept.
Ausweis, E-Rezept, alles klar.
Optionale Anwendungen sind die Medikamentenprüfung, den Notfalldatensatz, der elektronische Arztbrief und die elektronische Patientenakte. Und die elektronische Patientenakte und auch der elektronische Arztbrief sind also in weiter Zukunft. Das wäre also jetzt genau die Anwendung, wie du da gemeint hast. Ich würde gar nicht bestreiten, dass sowas nützlich sein könnte. Es ist aber eben stark die Frage, wie es implementiert ist. Wir werden nachher sicherlich nochmal auf die Sicherheit des Systems zu sprechen kommen. Wir müssen vorher dann auch überhaupt erst mal reden, was es bedeuten würde, wenn da was schiefgehen würde. Aber der Punkt ist, es hat in der Vergangenheit in Deutschland schon Implementierungen von sowas gegeben. Ich habe durch eine Kette interessanter Zufälle ein solches System mal dediziert und detailliert, sicherheitstechnisch untersucht. Und ich habe in meiner gesamten langen Karriere als Sicherheitsanalytiker noch niemals etwas so abgrundtief Schlechtes außerhalb eines Labors erlebt. Und das Ding ist real. Also meines Wissens nach ist es real mit Patienten eingesetzt worden. Und dann lieber drei unangenehme Untersuchungen als die Daten in so einem System. Auf keinen Fall. Man muss auch an dieser Stelle sagen, man hätte ja auch die Untersuchungsergebnisse sich von dem einen Arzt aushändigen lassen und mitnehmen können.
Das ist in der Tat, da habe ich mich mal damit beschäftigt, das ist eine Frage des Länderrechts. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel in Bayern hast du einen rechtlichen Anspruch darauf, dass du Untersuchungsergebnisse von einem Arzt dir aushändigen lässt. Den kannst du im Zweifelsfall einklagen. Das ist in anderen Bundesländern nicht so. Ich glaube in Berlin gibt sowas zum Beispiel nicht.
Und ich glaube dann gibt es sowas in Brandenburg auch nicht.
Denn ich habe danach gefragt.
Also spätestens als wir dann bei Nummer drei angekommen waren und sich meine Frau wieder auf diesen blöden Stuhl legen musste und die da wieder mit sämtlichen komischen Dingern rumgestochen haben, habe ich gefragt, ob es nicht irgendwie geht, ob die noch alle merken, was wir da machen. Das ist beim ersten Mal schon nicht gelaufen. Beim zweiten Mal war ich mir, ich hätte schon gekündigt irgendwie, als anstelle von meiner Frau. Und beim dritten Mal ging mir dann echt der Wut hoch. Und da war keiner, der mir das aushändigen wollte. Die haben mich dann nur angeguckt. Na, wir müssen doch wissen. Ich sag ja, aber alle drei, die dann am Ende nichts wissen. Ich sag, wie oft müssen wir denn noch so ein Scheiß machen? Die haben dann auch keine Antwort.
Ja gut, ich kenn jetzt natürlich den genaueren Umstände nicht. Es ist natürlich auch so, dass man gewisse Dinge wirklich nur nach Augenschein begutachten kann. Also jetzt, ich untersuche ja im IT-Sicherheitsbereich. Und da würde man ja häufig denken, da muss man überhaupt nicht vor Ort sein. Man muss nichts sehen. Man kann sich alle Sachen elektronisch schicken lassen und einfach nach Aktenlage urteilen. Und es ist einfach meine Erfahrung, selbst da funktioniert das nicht. Selbst da möchte ich gewisse Dinge sehen. Und selbst da finde ich auch noch Sachen einfach dadurch, dass ich mir selbst durch Augenschein ein Urteil bilde. Und das kann natürlich, soweit mir das Ärzte erzählen, im medizinischen Bereich natürlich noch viel stärker ausgeprägt.
Und möglicherweise ist ab 2012, dass es funktioniert realistisch, dann 2018 wahrscheinlich, oder?
Welche Chaosradio-Folge haben wir 2012 dann zu dem Thema?
Mit ein bisschen Glück erleben wir es ja gar nicht mehr.
Oder so. Ricardo, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Chaosradio 115, die Gesundheitskarte ist unser Thema heute Abend und der Crash, anrufen. Du hast noch eine Anmerkung, lese ich auf meinem Disko.
Ja, genau. Und zwar wollte ich mal anmerken, einen Kommentar zu meinem Vorvorredner, quasi der Erste, der angerufen hat, der sich die Mühe gemacht hat und mal die Stelle in der Aufbahrung rausgesucht hat. Und was ich noch anmerken wollte, ist, dass es bei den Tieren ja inzwischen so ist, dass es EU-weit den Beschluss gibt, schlaft seit fünf Jahren, korrigiert mich, wenn das nicht ganz hinhaut, die fünf Jahre. Aber ungefähr seit fünf Jahren ist es so, dass wenn ich meinen Hund zum Beispiel in europäischer Ausland mitnehmen möchte, der einen Chip braucht. Und ich denke mir, dass diese Gesundheitskarte, die jetzt kommt, quasi so eine Art Übergangsstufe ist zu diesem Chip.
Was für ein Chip ist das? Was macht der?
Der Chip wird implementiert unter die Haut des Tieres und enthält ähnliche Daten, zum Beispiel die Impfungsdaten und so weiter. Also alles gesundheit-relevante Daten und eine ID, also quasi eine Identifikation. Und inhaltlich ist es quasi genau das Gleiche, nur dass man es nicht mehr verlieren kann. Es wird dann mit verschiedenen Vorteilen begründet werden und so weiter und so fort. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass die Bibelstelle das meinen wird. Und zwar wird es dann so weit sein, ich sag jetzt mal so visionärerweise, da wird dann ein Personalausweis, Reisepass, Krankenkarte, EC-Karte, Kreditkarte und alles was halt in die Richtung geht, was man quasi zum täglichen Leben hier in der westlichen Welt so braucht. In diesem Chip, der dann auch nicht mehr verloren werden kann, der dann nicht mehr bestohlen werden kann und so weiter und so fort. Vielleicht noch mit einem antiterroristischen Gesetz zur Identifikation wird das dann per Gesetz erlassen, dass jeder verpflichtet wird, so ein Teil sich einpflanzen zu lassen. Und das geht über das Tier. Also viele Menschen gewöhnen sich an den Gedanken, dass es okay ist, wenn man so ein Chip dann bei sich trägt, weil bei den Tieren wird das ja schon seit vielen Jahren gemacht und so weiter und so fort. Und ich denke halt, dass diese Krankenkarte nur so eine Zwischenstufe sein wird und dass damit dann quasi diese Offenbarung auch vollzogen sein wird.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt die Offenbarung, aber trotzdem interessanter Punkt. Danke für deinen Anruf, Crash. Ist das irgendwie was in Planung? Also ist das realistisch, dass das nur ein Zwischenschritt ist dahin, dass wir unsere ganzen Daten dann tatsächlich mit uns rumtragen, in irgendeiner Form an den Körper gebunden?
Also sagen wir mal, wir wollen ja ein bisschen bei der Gesundheitskarte bleiben. Aber dann nehmen wir mal die Notfalldaten. Es ist eine der großen Versprechungen, mit der elektronischen Gesundheitskarte hat man den gigantischen Vorteil, dass man jetzt immer seine Notfalldaten dabei hat. Man wird also von einem Notarzt nie falsch behandelt werden und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Vorausgesetzt, ich hab das Ding in der Tasche.
Ja, da kommen wir nämlich genau zu dem spannenden Punkt. Also ich wildere daher jetzt außerhalb meines Fachgebietes, aber ich habe genügend Notärzte, die mir das so bestätigt haben. Die sagen, was müssen wir denn... Also wie lange müssen wir einen Patienten nach einer Gesundheitskarte durchsuchen? Das wird noch lega artis, also kunstgerecht handeln. Wenn wir die Gesundheitskarte gefunden haben, wie lange müssen wir denn am Computer rumprobieren, bis wir die gelesen haben? Also ich meine, die ist ja vielleicht blutverschmiert, dann Kontakte, das funktioniert ja alles nicht so gut. Was machen wir, wenn wir zwei finden? Ja, weil die Karte brauche ich auch, um ein Rezept einzulösen. Wenn jetzt jemand krank ist, früher hat er sein Papierrezept weitergegeben, jetzt muss er seine Gesundheitskarte mit seinen Notfalldaten weitergeben. Jetzt ist also der nette Nachbar, der das Rezept einlösen geht, hat es ab zwei dabei, verunglückt auf der Straße. Ich finde zwei.
Ja, und verunglückt zum Beispiel so, dass man ihn jetzt am Gesicht nicht mehr so eindeutig identifizieren kann, weil da ist ja ein Foto drauf und so.
Das ist natürlich hinreichend abwegig, aber es ist möglich.
Ja, oder die Frage, ich habe einen ganz normalen Busunfall. Sollen jetzt die Sanitäter Memory mit Gesundheitskarten und Patienten spielen? Ich meine, muss ich ja nur die typischen Bilder von einem Busunfall oder von einem Bahnunfall? Anschauen, da sind die Leute ja von ihren persönlichen Besitztümern getrennt. Also wir haben da ein ganz massives Problem. Die Zuordnung der Daten zur Person, die ist einfach nicht zuverlässig. Was heißt, es bringt keine Nutzen? Also zum Beispiel eine Blutgruppe wird immer gesagt, da haben sie ihre Blutgruppe auf dem im Notfall Datenpass, sagen die Notärzte. Und selbst wenn sie die Blutgruppe auf die Stirn tätowiert hätten, zusammen mit dem Siegel des Amtsarztes.
So viele Blutkonserven können die gar nicht mit rumschleppen für alle Fälle, oder?
Nein, er ist gesetzlich verpflichtet und da ändert sich auch nichts dran. Alles andere wäre fahrlässig. Er muss, bevor er eine Transfusion macht, eh einen Bluttest machen. Es ist also völlig egal, ob das Ding auf dem Notfallpass steht und ob ich den dabei habe und ob er den gesucht und gefunden hat. Er muss seine Tests machen und er fährt ohnehin seine Standardroutinen ab.
Gott sei Dank möchte ich noch behaupten, muss er das machen.
Natürlich.
Vielleicht stehen wir ja in zwei Jahren dann bei dem Punkt, dass es dann heißt, der muss da keinen Test mehr machen, wenn es falsch in dem Ausweis steht oder wie auch immer, dann hat er halt Pech gehabt. Das wäre die logische Konsequenz dann mittelfristig.
So, jetzt sozusagen zu dem Anrufer von eben zurückzukommen. Natürlich ist es eine naheliegende Idee, dass man die Gesundheitskarte unter die Haut transplantiert, um dieses Zuordnungsproblem zu lösen. Und damit eröffnen sich natürlich Missbrauchspotenziale. Die sind also wirklich atemberaubend. Und es ist im Übrigen...
Das Thema ist die Gesundheitskarte, atemberaubend. Wir wollen natürlich nicht einfach mit dem Wort atemberaubend aufhören, sondern euch auch wirklich den Atem berauben.
Das Argument ist ja solche, jetzt ist der Missbrauchsschutz höher, sondern unter die Haut implantierten Schipp, den kann man ja nicht stehlen, haben wir ja gerade eben gehört. Genau. Und es gibt ein Beispiel, das ist in Malaysia wirklich passiert, dessen Geschäftsmann überfallen worden. Der war auf die schlaue Idee gekommen, seinen Luxuswagen über einen biometrischen Fingerprint-Leser zu sichern. Der ist überfallen worden und wir haben ja in der IT-Sicherheit haben wir immer so diese klassischen drei Authentifikationsinstrumente. Wissen, also die PIN seiner Karten, Besitz, also die Kredit- und Bankkarten, die er hatte und Eigenschaften, Biometrie. Und man sagt also im Normalfall, wenn ich ein System habe, was alle drei Komponenten enthält, dann ist das wahnsinnig sicher. Nach kurzem Vorhalten einer Machete hat also dieser Geschäftsmann natürlich relativ bereitwillig seine PIN abgegeben, hat seine Karten abgegeben. Das mit dem Auto war nicht ganz so einfach. Nachdem es dann den Gangstern zu mühselig war, den immer aus dem Kofferraum rauszupacken, das Auto zu starten, ihn wieder in den Kofferraum reinzupacken, kam sie irgendwann auf die naheliegende Idee. Dann war der Finger halt ab. Und jetzt kann man sich überlegen, was passiert, wenn wir als Sicherheitsmerkmale Dinge implantieren. Wenn wir einfach die Geschichte der Sicherheitsmaßnahmen über die letzten 30 Jahre betrachten, dann sehen wir, dass dieses Hochrüsten in den Sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu mehr Gewalt und zu schlimmerer Kriminalität geführt hat. Vor 30 Jahren hat sich jemand vor mich hingestellt und hat gesagt, Geld oder Leben.
Dann hat er das Portemonnaie gekriegt.
Und dann muss er mich vorzugsweise noch längere Zeit daran hindern, dass ich das ganze Ding sperren kann, was also zu einigen sehr hässlichen Verbrechen geführt hat, die vor allem Frauen treffen. Und jetzt nehmen wir Biometrie dazu. Na herzlichen Glückwunsch. Also ich trenne mich lieber von meinem Portemonnaie. Und dann scheiden wir einigermaßen in Freundschaft. Weil ich ja auch durchaus in der Wahl, also die Wahl habe, wie viel Geld ich in welche Kontexte mitnehme. Wenn ich jetzt eine Karte dabei habe, habe ich immer einen vollen Verfügungsrahmen dabei, der ist ziemlich viel wert. Also im Verhältnis zu, ich gehe auf irgendein Fest und sag, naja gut, ich nehme jetzt halt 20 Euro mit, mehr werde ich an dem Abend nicht verzeichen. Und wenn mir die jemand wegnimmt, gut, ich hätte es halt lieber verkonsumiert.
Aber kann man auch noch mitleben. Ja, mit einem Auge weniger wird es hart.
Ja, eben.
Gut, noch ein weiterer Aspekt, noch ganz kurz als Ergänzung zu den implantierten RFIDs in dem Kontext. Ja, da haben wir auch wieder ganz andere, schon rein auf ganz unterster technischer Ebene ganz andere Probleme. Also eine Chipkarte, die tatsächlich irgendwo über Kontakte ausgelesen wird, das ist nochmal ganz eine andere Thematik als irgendwas, was über Funk aus der Ferne unter Umständen ausgelesen wird. Da kommt eine ganz andere Debatte rein, aber das ist in jedem Fall ein Punkt. Und die Chips, wie sie im Moment, also das ist ein sogenanntes Glastransponder, die bei den Haustieren eingesetzt werden, die sind zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht gegen Fälschungen oder irgendwas gesichert. Also da kann man wunderbar eins zu eins Kopien davon machen. Weil einfach Sicherheit nicht wirklich der Grund ist, warum man die einführt.
Sondern?
Na, was weiß der Teufel.
Leichte Identifizierbarkeit der Haustiere.
Richtig, wenn sie auf der Päckel laufen sind.
Und Verfolgbarkeit der Nutztiere. Also da geht es dann eben um solche Dinge wie BSE. Ich möchte halt ein Nutztier quasi ab der Geburt bis zur Fleichtage verfolgen können, detailliert. Und da mag das dann durchaus eine nützliche, aber auf keinen Fall fälschungssichere Instrument sein. Und im Gesundheitswesen reden wir aber natürlich über ganz, ganz andere Schadenspotenziale. Also wir haben das ja schon angerissen. Was passiert eben, wenn diese Daten in falsche Hände kommen? Dann kann ich Ableitungen machen über die Krankheitswahrscheinlichkeit der Kinder und Kindeskinder der Person. Und wenn Versicherungen und Arbeitgeber das in die Hände bekommen, dann kann das natürlich gravierend auf deren Entscheidungen einwirken. Ich meine, warum sollte ein Versicherer ein schlechtes Risiko versichern? Warum sollte ein Arbeitgeber jemanden nehmen, von dem er aufgrund der Krankheitsvorgeschichte der Eltern beispielsweise weiß, dass mit einer überdurchschnittlich hohen Fehlzeit zu rechnen ist?
Zwei Anrufe habe ich noch in der Leitung. Jan, hallo.
Hallo.
Du hast eine alternative Lösung, lese ich hier bei mir.
Ja, beziehungsweise einen Ansatz einer alternativen Lösung. Nämlich, es wird ja geplant für jeden Zweck, eine völlig intransparente Karte durchzusetzen, mit sehr hohem Missbrauchspotenzial. Im Prinzip sind das ja kleine Smartcats, die dann nur eine ID enthalten und zur Identifizierung dienen. Die liefert man dem Arzt dann aus. Der hat Kontrolle darüber, sobald man ihm den PIN gibt. Und kann dann mit den Daten, die da drüber stehen, rausfinden, wer man ist und auf die entsprechenden Einträge einer zentralen Datenbank zugreifen. Und meine Idee wäre jetzt, das Ganze umzukehren und dezentral zu machen. Zum Beispiel über eine Art USB-Stick, jetzt nur als vereinfachtes Modell, mit einer Hardware-Krypto-Lösung und einem einbruchsichieren Chip. Die Daten da drauf werden wie auf einem USB-Stick abgelegt, also für den einzelnen bequem lesbar. So kann man jederzeit feststellen, was da über einem drin steht. Die Daten werden vor Ort in dem eigenen Chip abgelegt und dürfen dann halt nur in einem Offline-System genutzt werden. Und die Verschungssicherheit wird einfach durch die Signaturen sichergestellt. Das ist das Problem in der entsprechenden PKI aufbauen, der man vertrauen kann. Und das ist halt anders als die klassische kleine Smartcard, weil die Daten sind noch im eigenen Besitz. Man könnte es auch sinnvoll nutzen, zum Beispiel Signaturen hinterlegen, sodass man sie nur schreiben und damit signieren kann oder vielleicht noch einen Hasch rauskriegen. Und die Frage ist, wie man so ein Ding trauen kann. Halt wäre, die Hardware-Beschreibung in einer Open-Source-Lizenz abzufassen, also in der Hardware-Beschreibungssprache und den Quelltext in einer Open-Source-Lizenz und das Ganze dann in einem FPGA-Synthetisierenden, den man fälschungssicher machen kann, durch irgendwie Setzbaurefuses und Hardware-Einbauschutz. Nur das Problem ist, dass diese Lösung halt sehr viel Wissen beim Einzelnen voraussetzt. Da hatte ich jetzt die letzten Tage mal so drüber nachgedacht.
Warum setzt das viel Wissen beim Einzelnen voraus? Also wenn ich einfach einen Pömpel am Schlüsselbund habe, wo meine Daten drauf gespeichert sind und das gebe ich zum Arzt, dem ich ja sowieso vertraue. Eben. Solange das dezentral offline ist, ist mein Vertrauen ja noch da.
Ich suche mir ja einen Arzt meines Vertrauens. Also diesen Begriff gibt es ja nicht umsonst.
Von daher wäre selbst für Leute wie mich, die jetzt vielleicht, ich sag mal so ein Drittel von dem, was du da gerade gesagt hast, gar nicht verstanden haben, wäre das auch kein Problem.
Dann vereinfacht gesagt, es ist ein stinknormaler USB-Chip.
Verstanden hab ich das. Ich meine, so ein Hasch und was auch immer du da geredet hast. Verstehe ich nicht, muss ich aber auch gar nicht, weil ich das einfach die Idee einer dezentralen Offline-Lösung mit einfach einem persönlichen Vertrauensverhältnis zu irgendeiner anderen Person, die dann meinen Arzt, das finde ich sehr, sehr bestechen und finde ich sehr, sehr sexy eigentlich.
Und ja, vor allem die Idee, wenn man sagt, man kann diesem Ding vertrauen, also wenn das Ding wird ja zum Beispiel dann sehr wichtig, wenn man es universell einsetzen kann, weil auf einem Chip, wenn er einem gehört und man vielleicht auch von diversen Herstellern bzw. wenn man es kann, sogar selber herstellen kann, so ein Ding, wäre tatsächlich auch ein Vertrauen da. Zig Leute würden sich das Ding angucken, auseinandernehmen, dadurch wäre es sehr, sehr schwierig, die Dinger zu manipulieren einfach. Jeder könnte seine Daten noch selber unter Kontrolle halten und wenn man vergleicht, so ein Ding zu bauen, kostet vielleicht im Einzelfall irgendwie 30 Euro. Das kostet es einmal und es ist nicht nur eine riesige Struktur, die permanent am Laufen gehalten werden muss und es bietet viel weniger Angriffsmöglichkeiten.
Ein Satz als Antwort oder auch als Zusammenfassung zu dem Thema ist, dass wir uns ja nicht grundsätzlich gegen sinnvollen Einsatz von Technologie im Gesundheitswesen sträuben. Wir sind ja selber Leute, die sehr viel mit Technologie zu tun haben, die eigentlich schon sehr technophil sind. Aber der Punkt ist einfach, dass wir gerade zum Beispiel bei der Gesundheitskarte einfach mit der Art und Weise und der konkreten Umsetzung dessen nicht einverstanden sind und der Meinung sind, das müsste anders gemacht werden. Und jetzt aus meiner persönlichen Sicht, eine dezentrale Lösung ist in jedem Fall, eigentlich egal bei was, immer zu bevorzugen. Weil, also du hast, du hast keinen, ja bitte?
Selbst beim Steuern zahlen.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Und der einzige Punkt, was du sozusagen nicht willst, ist, dass du der Einzige bist, der deine Daten hat. Du willst, dass die Ärzte deines Vertrauens Kopien haben, weil dein Stick könnte kaputt gehen, verloren gehen etc.
Nein, das ist ja nicht mal ein Problem, wenn der Stick kaputt geht, Entschuldigung, dass ich jetzt ins Wort falle, aber man könnte ja jederzeit diese Daten auf dein Rechner speichern.
Das würde ich für eine mäßig gute Idee halten.
Nein, das ist kein Problem, weil da ja Hardware-Kryptographie in dem Stick ist, speichert man die reinen Binärdaten verschlüsselt und hält den Schlüssel auf dein Chip, merkt sich eine PIN oder im Notfall könnte man noch die Betriebe nutzen.
Der Chip ist weg.
Ich kaufe mir einen oder organisiere mir einen, baue mir einen, ist doch...
Aber dein Schlüssel ist weg.
Doch.
Wenn der nur auf dem Chip war, ist er weg. Cool, wenn er auf deinem Rechner ist, dann ist er aus anderen Gründen weg.
Das meinte ich nicht. Der Schlüssel, sobald man ja eine Hardwarelösung hat, kann man ja die Anzahl der Schlüsselversuche wahrscheinlich, ein geschicktes Protokoll hart auch über die Hardware reduzieren.
Na gut, also wir verfangen uns den Details. Ich denke, wir sollten zur allgemeinen Diskussion um die Gesundheitskarte hinzukommen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall wäre ja möglich, dass zum Beispiel der Schlüssel irgendwie nachstelliger Pin ist oder so.
Also wir können die Diskussion technisch an dieser Stelle nicht vertiefen, weil wir dann wirklich einen Großteil der Zuhörer abhängen würden.
Ich hab ja schon angefangen Käsekästchen zu malen.
Ja, glaub einfach, hier sitzen im Studio zwei Leute, die sich ziemlich intensiv mit IT-Sicherheit und mit Kryptographie beschäftigen. Und ganz so einfach ist es an dieser Stelle nicht. Was nicht heißt, dass dein Vorschlag schlecht ist. Dein Vorschlag ist sicherlich zu 98 bis 99 Prozent völlig richtig. Da stimmen wir völlig zu. Und es geht wirklich nur um ein paar kleine technische Kleinigkeiten, die wir dann auch gerne mal offline diskutieren können.
Also wenn Jan draufkommt, wenn wir draufkommen, warum wird es nicht so gemacht? Gibt es eine offizielle Begründung dafür, dass sowas nicht gemacht wird?
Offizielle Begründung kann ich dir nicht geben, aber ich kann dir natürlich sagen, warum es so ist.
Ach doch, jetzt machen wir die offizielle Begründung. Also, ich meine, da müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen ins Eingemachte gehen. Nämlich, dieses Projekt ist ja von ziemlich langer Hand vorbereitet. Und schon 2004 wurde der Ulla Schmidt von einem sogenannten Bit-vor-Hells-Konsortium die Rahmenarchitektur übergeben. Die kann man finden beim www.dimdi.de.
Also, wer ist dieses Konsortium?
Ich habe jetzt nicht alle Namen, die da drin beteiligt sind, auswendig im Kopf, aber das kann man also nachschlagen. Der entscheidende Punkt ist, dass das bei diesem Deutschen Institut für medizinische Daten und für medizinische Dokumentation und Information, kann man das alles finden. Dieser Teilbereich, da steht das Bundesgesundheitsministerium auch als Ansprechpartner drin. Also das wissen die, das ist denen auch offiziell übergeben worden. Das ist auch in der Version 1.0 übergeben worden und weiterentwickelt worden zur Version 1.1. Und also überall steht, dass diese Rahmenarchitektur den Rahmen setzt, deswegen heißt die auch so, für die jetzt nachfolgenden Lösungsarchitekturen, von denen es verschiedene gibt, die parallel in den Modellregionen ausprobiert werden sollen. Und wenn man sich jetzt in dieser Rahmenarchitektur die Sicherheitsanforderungen anschaut, dann kann einem einiges klar werden. Ich muss hier gerade mal die richtigen Dinge dazu raussuchen. Und zwar gibt es da einige Sicherheitsanforderungen, die schon ziemlich spannend sind.
Ich kann an der Stelle mal kurz einspringen, kann sagen, wer hinter BitforHealth steckt. Das ist IBM Deutschland, der Chipkartenhersteller Orga, SAP und dem Spezialisten für Patientenakten Intercomponentware.
Das heißt niemand, der wirklich was mit Gesundheit zu tun hat.
Doch, naja, um noch einen Schritt weiter zurückzugehen, von da, wo wir eigentlich herkamen, warum ist das System so wie es ist und warum macht das niemand dezentral und vielleicht irgendwie wie der Patient davon profitieren würde, weil hier ein Konsortium mit der Erarbeitung eines Konzepts beauftragt wird ohne Ausschreibungen ohne irgendwie sonst Prozesse, die in der öffentlichen, also wie öffentliche Aufzeige geteilt werden, eben zustande kommen.
Ja und zum Beispiel ist ja auch, sind die Mediziner da überhaupt nicht richtig zu Wort gekommen?
Nein, nein.
Ist das denn vielleicht einklagbar? Also ist das vielleicht ein Hebel, um dieses Ding zu stoppen, dass man sagt, hier im Moment mal keine Ausschreibung, kein gar nichts, wo kommen wir denn dahin?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Wahrscheinlich könnte da aber dann wieder nur aus Wettbewerbsgründen irgendwie jemand flaggen, der sozusagen ein Gegenangebot oder so hätte einbringen wollen.
Naja, da kann man doch schnell zusammenzimmern. Und dann USB-Stick, auf dem die Daten sind, und zwar rund für Schlüssel.
Ja, aber er hätte ja damals ein Gebot einreichen müssen.
Aber ich denke, es gab keine Ausschreibung.
Ja gut, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob es eine Ausschreibung gab.
Es ist auf jeden Fall alles ziemlich dubios gelaufen mit diesem Projekt. Was Gesundheitskartenprojekte im Allgemeinen zu schaffen, also offensichtlich haben, also in Österreich zum Beispiel mit der Gesundheitskarte, da ist die Gesundheitskarte mittlerweile ein Dauerbrenner im Rechnungshofsbericht. Also jedes Jahr, wenn man den österreichischen Bericht des Rechnungshofs sich anschaut, dann taucht da die Gesundheitskarte, also die E-Card, wie sie dort heißt, auf. Und also auch, weil da Leute beauftragt werden ohne Ausschreibung und Gehälter gezahlt werden für Dinge, die gar nicht umgekehrt definiert sind.
Was der Rechnungshof erzählt hat, hat die Bundesregierung hier bei uns ja auch noch nie interessiert.
Ja eben, ich sag ja nur.
Aber was da in Österreich abgeht, ist schon hochgradig spannend. Dabei muss man wissen, die Österreicher machen viel, viel weniger als wir. Die machen nur die Ausweisfunktion und die Abrechnung darüber. Und da passieren schon ziemlich spannende Dinge. Also sehr interessant bei www.hauserzteverband.at Da muss man sich mal das E-Card Tagebuch anschauen. Da berichtet ein Arzt, der also ganz begeistert und ganz früh am Modellversuch teilgenommen hat. Und dann war halt die Einführung jetzt, also der ist jetzt halt etwa anderthalb Jahre oder so dabei. Und es ist einfach sehr interessant zu sehen, wie dieser Arzt von einem sehr innovationsfreundlichen Technikbegeisterten zu einem massiven Kritiker der österreichischen E-Card geworden ist, die da da weniger gemacht wird, kostet die die Praxen eine Stunde pro Tag. Es hat in drei Monaten, also in den ersten drei Monaten, glaube ich, nach der offiziellen Einführung, hat es drei Totalausfälle über mehrere Stunden gegeben, die alle immer als Super-Gauss bezeichnet wurden. Also bei Kernkraftwerken gibt Super-Gauss nur etwa alle zehn Millionen Jahre. Bei der elektronischen Gesundheitskarte gab es die da teilweise im Wochenabstand, also teilweise sogar innerhalb weniger Tage. Regionale Ausfälle oder lokale Ausfälle sind absolut an der Tagesordnung. Die zählt schon lange keiner mehr. Es gibt so nette Sprüche, wie die E-Card hat immer recht, die eine gewisse Pikanterie in Situationen kriegen, die dieser Arzt erlebt hat. Er sagt irgendwann, es steht eine langjährig bekannte Patientin vor mir. Die steckt ihre Schippkarte ein und ich erhalte die Anzeige. Ich darf sie nicht behandeln, die ist nämlich tot.
Gab es noch so ein Film mit Sandra Bullock?
Ja, es gab mal deutschen Science Fiction. Das löste man dann damit, dass man die Person, die den Daten nicht mehr entsprach, tatsächlich dann beerdigt hat. Da in Österreich ging es etwas klimpflicher aus. Man hat also nach mehreren Wochen intensiven Bemühens diese Frau wieder ins Leben zurück gekriegt auf der E-Card. Und die Ursache war interessant. Ich meine, es sterben ja immer Menschen, da ist halt jemand verstorben. Und beim Eingeben dessen Nummer gab es einen Zahlendreher. Und damit ist dann eben diese Frau als totgezeichnet worden. Und sowas muss man sich jetzt natürlich auch mal mit medizinischen Daten vorstellen. Solche Fälle hat es also in den USA gegeben. Sogenannten, in diesem Fall, also gezielt sogar, Medical Identity Self, das heißt, haben sich Leute unter fremden Namen behandeln lassen. Dann standen natürlich in den Gesundheitsakten auch falsche medizinische Daten drin. Das ist jetzt in den USA nur deswegen sozusagen glücklich rausgekommen, ehe es dramatische medizinische Folgen hatte, weil die Patienten da alle eine Rechnung kriegen. Und dann sagt er halt, Entschuldigung Leute, ihr habt mir kein Bindum operiert. Hier, guckt, da ist keine Nabe. Ihr könnt mich nicht operiert haben. Jetzt stellt man sich aber so was mal im deutschen Gesundheitswesen vor. Dann kommt jemand mit einem akuten Blinddarm ins Krankenhaus. Die Chipkarte wird gesteckt. Der Arzt sagt, ist ja komisch. Ich hätte ja drauf gewettet, dass der ein Blinddarmdurchbruch hat.
Aber der hat ja schon gar kein Blinddarm mehr drin.
Der hat ja nicht mehr drin, ja. Also suchen wir mal nach was anderem.
Na ja gut, da muss man aber schon dann bei diesem Szenario irgendwie wieder mit berücksichtigen, dass ja die Ausweisfunktionalität in der Karte drin ist. Wie kann denn jemand anders sich behandeln lassen mit meiner Karte?
Na ja, der braucht sich... Also erstens mal, natürlich kann man diese Karten genau so weitergeben, wie man sie jetzt weitergibt. Man kann natürlich auch die PIN mit weitergeben. Punkt eins. Punkt zwei. Wir haben ja gesehen, es muss überall ein papierbasierter Ersatzprozess sein. Und da gibt es natürlich eine Datennacherfassung. Und wie wird so eine Datennacherfassung passieren? Die wird natürlich über die versicherten Nummer passieren. Und da kann es natürlich wieder zu Zahlendrehern kommen. Oder es wird aus einer Selectbox, kennen wir doch alle so, klick und Selectbox und ziehen und ach, schade, knapp daneben. Und schon sind die medizinischen Daten im manuellen Nachbereitungsprozess in der falschen Patientenakte gelangt. Und da stecken die erstmal drin. Da kommen wir übrigens auch zu dieser schönen Bezug zu der Stasi. Jeder von uns wird also eine Personenkennziffer kriegen. Und diese Personenkennziffer ist aufgebaut aus Geburtsdatum, Geschlecht und Postleitzahl.
Was denn, wenn ich umziehe?
Ja, das ist interessant. Ich kann das also hier auch mal gleich zeigen. Nein, ich kann es nicht zeigen. Ich habe so viele Vorträge gehalten. Ich bin gewohnt, ich habe einen Beamer. Das ist so festgeschrieben in Sicherheitsanforderungen. Es ist unterspezifiziert. Es ist nicht klar, welche Postleitzahl. Mit hoher Sicherheit wird es die erste Postleitzahl sein, unter der man gemeldet war. Also sozusagen der Geburtswohnort. Jetzt kann man zeigen, das ist natürlich kein Pseudonym. Das wird als Pseudonym verwendet. Wir müssen gleich noch zu einem Punkt aus Sicherheitsanforderungen kommen. In der DDR gab es die sogenannte Personenkennziffer. Diese Personenkennziffer benutzte die Stasi als eindeutige Identifizierungsmethode. Die bestand aus Geburtsdatum, Geschlecht und dem Melderegister, wo man bei der Geburt gemeldet war.
So jetzt haben wir genug Gänsehaut erzeugt.
Also ich hab mal für Erfurt recherchiert. In Erfurt gab es elf solcher Meldestellen. In Erfurt gibt es heute zwölf geografische Postleitzahlen. Das Netz ist also enger geworden. Die PKZ hatte hinten noch so Prüfzeffer dran, um Kollisionen aufzulösen. Das wird natürlich auch bei der versicherten Nummer da sein. Der interessante Punkt ist aber, welche Daten gebe ich einem Arbeitgeber? Welche Daten gebe ich einem Versicherer? Der kriegt natürlich mein Geburtsdatum. Geschlecht kann er am Namen ablesen, wenn es nicht explizit abgefragt wird. Dann hat er sowohl meinen Wohnort, als auch häufig meinen Geburtsort. Das heißt also, diese Nummer kann er jetzt generieren. Und es ist ihm auch egal, ob er Kollisionen hat. Wenn er jetzt so einen Sack, sagen wir mal, von drei Leuten hat und einer von denen wäre ein ganz schlechtes Gesundheitsrisiko, dann versichert er halt lieber alle drei nicht, weil er die Kollision nicht auflösen kann. Ist ihm egal, ja? Er macht trotzdem ein besseres Geschäft.
Das zusammen mit einer Entsolidarisierung, sodass dann auch irgendwann, also ich meine, die Regierung arbeitet nach meinem Dafürhalten ja gerade daran, dass irgendwann eine Solidargemeinschaft nicht mehr existiert, sodass sich niemand mehr für den anderen verpflichtet fühlt. Und es gibt tatsächlich endlos Leute, die durchs Raster fallen. Das ist eine unangenehme Vorstellung.
Also wir müssen hier einfach gleich mal was vorlesen. Das ist original aus den Sicherheitsanforderungen. Und zwar in diesen Sicherheitsanforderungen, die sind alle nummeriert und die, die ich jetzt vorlese ist die VAS 1. Einfach nur, falls das mal jemand nachlesen möchte. Eine Pseudonymisierung des Versicherten- und Leistungserbringerbezugs wird von der Vertrauensstelle durchgeführt und findet in der Form statt, dass bundesweit periodenübergreifende Auswertungen zu einem Versicherten- und Leistungserbringer durchgeführt werden können. Pseudonyme enthalten bestimmte Bestandteile, Geburtsdatum, Geschlecht, Postleitzahl. Das ist also dieses Pseudonym, von dem ich eben geredet habe. Und wenn man jetzt diese Anforderungen in normales Umgangsdeutsch zurück übersetzt, dann heißt das, es gibt Instanzen. Und diese Instanzen werden zum Beispiel unter anderem die Krankenkassen sein. Die können periodenübergreifend, also quartalsübergreifende Auswertungen fahren, bis auf die Ebene einzelner Ärzte und einzelner Patienten. Das heißt, also die können sich im Prinzip die gesamte Krankengeschichte einer Person anschauen. Und das ist offensichtlich nicht verschlüsselt. Da wird gesagt, das ist unbedenklich, weil man hat ja keinen Namen. Man hat ja nur diese Pseudonyme. Diese Pseudonyme kann man natürlich auflösen. Die Stasi hat mit dieser PKZ ihre zentrale Personendatenbank betrieben. Das heißt, das hat hervorragend funktioniert, um Personen eindeutig zu identifizieren. Und diese neue Nummer hat eine ganz analoge Struktur. Und es sind Daten, die jeder Arbeitgeber, jeder Versicherer von mir bekommt. Sonst bekomme ich keine Chance. Und es braucht, man kann sich jetzt ganz verschiedene Szenarien vorstellen. In Österreich ist es interessanterweise so, dass die Versicherungen und die Arbeitgeber sogar Zugriff auf diese Datenbank haben. Natürlich nur freiwillig mit dem Einverständnis des Bürgers.
Wenn du nicht zum Gentest gehst, warst du eben der Vergewaltiger.
Genau. Oder man kriegt dann halt diese Einwilligungsbogen hingestellt, das Tesschen Kaffee daneben. Und wenn man dann das nicht binnen einer Minute unterschrieben hat, dann geht halt der Interviewpartner vom potenziellen Arbeitgeber weg, wünscht einem noch einen schönen Tag. Man dürfe in Ruhe seinen Kaffee ausdringen. Man braucht sich auch nur vorstellen, es braucht bei den Krankenversicherern nur einen einzigen korrupten Mitarbeiter zu geben, der sich einfach ein Zubrot verdient.
Den gibt es.
Natürlich. Sowas hatten wir schon im Kraftfahrtbundesamt.
Gibt es überall.
Oder die Familie sitzt halt zu Hause mit dem Messer am Hals. Also selbst wenn alle unbestechlich sein sollten, was schon unwahrscheinlich genug ist. Also wir sehen einfach, dieses System ist nicht dicht zu kriegen. Und wir werden auch Zehntausende von Arbeitsplatzrechnern haben, die diese Zugriffsfunktionalität haben. Und die werden einfach gezielt angegriffen werden. Und wir schaffen es ja in der Industrie auch nicht, die Arbeitsplatzrechner sicher zu halten. Da passiert genügend. Irgendein Zero-Day-Exploit und die Dinger sind offen und gezielt angegriffen. Dann hat jemand ein Botnet auf Krankenkassenrechnern und zieht sich diese Daten. Diese Daten sind richtig viel Geld wert.
Es waren einmal viele junge Menschen aus der Lausitz. Die hatten einen gemeinsamen Musikgeschmack namens Alternative, Indie und deutschen Rockpop. Aber sie waren sehr betrübt, weil der Weg zu den Konzerten und Festivals immer sehr weit und beschwerlich war. Aber dann kam das Populario.
Fritz präsentiert das Populario-Festival 2006 mit Chikinki, Tokotronic, Northern Light, Virginia Jetzt und am Strand den Shadow of Lones. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Das Populario-Festival Freitag, 18. August auf den Flugplatz Nard bei Hoyerswerde Mehr Infos.
Fritz von RBB 2 und halb 12. Fritz Info Nachrichten mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
UNO Generalsekretär Anan hat das Bedauern Israels über die Tötung von vier Blauhelmsoldaten im Süd Libanon angenommen. Er habe dem israelischen Ministerpräsidenten Olmott eine gemeinsame Untersuchung vorgeschlagen, sagte Anan nach einem Telefonat mit Olmott. Bei dem Luftangriff im Libanon waren gestern Abend vier UN-Soldaten getötet worden. Die Kämpfe im Süd Libanon und im Gaza-Streifen gingen ungeachtet der internationalen diplomatischen Bemühungen weiter. Ein israelischer General erklärte, die Offensive könne noch Wochen dauern. Bei Gefechten um den Ort Bint Jibail wurden acht Soldaten getötet. Die Hezbollah feuerte mehrere hundert Raketen auf Nordisrael ab, mehrere Dutzende Menschen wurden verletzt. Im Zusammenhang mit der Korruptionsaffäre in der Autoindustrie hat der VW-Konzern heute Strafanzeige gestellt. Die Anzeige richte sich gegen alle Personen, die zum Nachteil der Volkswagen AG handeln, und teilte der Konzern mit. Die Staatsanwaltschaften in Frankfurt und München verdächtigen den französischen Zulieferer Francia an Einkäufer, bei VW, Audi und BMW jahrelang Schmiergelder gezahlt zu haben. Die Verhandlungen im Tarifstreit der kommunalen Klinikärzte sind nach fünfwochiger Dauer festgefahren. Der Vorsitzende des Marburger Bundes Montgomery sagte in Ingolstadt, die Arbeitgeber seien weder bereit, ein neues Angebot vorzulegen, noch hätten sie sich auf eine Schlichtung eingelassen. Laut Marburger Bund haben heute 15.000 Ärzte an kommunalen Krankenhäusern gestreikt. Zwei Fußball-Testspielergebnisse. NRG Cottbus hat in einem Testspielhalt gegen Atletico Madrid 1-1 unentschieden gespielt. Hertha wiederum hat bei St. Pauli 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Nacht bleibt trocken, Temperaturen sacken auf 20 bis 15 Grad. Morgen dann wieder viel Sonne und maximal 36 Grad. Achtung, wegen der Hitze ist im Moment höchste Waldbrandgefahr. Der Verkehr auf Ritz mit einer Meldung A111. Der Autobahn zu Bringer Richtung Hamburg, allerdings statt einwärts Richtung Charlottenburg. Zwischen Weidmanns-Lusterdamm, Hermsdorfer-Damm und Kurt-Schumacher-Damm sind in Standhaltungsarbeiten heute Nacht, dort ist die A111 deswegen gesperrt. Ansonsten nichts Aktuelles, gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Gerald Kötter-Einrich, 4 Minuten und halb 12.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder...
Das Chaosradio 115 ist es, dass ihr hört und die Gesundheitskarte ist unser Thema heute Abend. Zwei Anrufe haben wir noch in der Leitung, das eine ist der Tilmar. Grüß dich Tilmar.
Ja, guten Tag.
Ja?
Hört ihr da eigentlich fest dazu?
Hört ihr was? Ja, ja, wir hören dich, sag mal was.
Ja, weil es geht mir darum, ihr habt die ganzen negativen Seiten jetzt schon mal rausgearbeitet.
Waren das alle?
Ach nein, da gibt es ja noch so viel. Nein, aber die andere Frage ist die positive Seite des, wo man sagt, Vertrauensabs. Wenn ich zum Abs gehe und was habe, heißt, wenn ich auf der Chipkarte irgendwas zu stehen habe oder irgendwas, was mir unbedingt schnell nötig bedürftig ist, ohne großen Aufwand zu bekommen, ist es doch für mich eindeutig besser. Nur, wie gesagt, da müsste ein gewisser Schutz vor sein. Ich muss da so schön lecheln, wo ihr gesagt habt, Stasi-Achte und weiß ich nicht was. Da gibt es so viele Möglichkeiten, um so was zu umgehen. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin Ein-Eier-Zwelling. Und wir haben das Problem gehabt, dass mein Bruder, also mein Zwillingsbruder, an der Grenze angehalten worden ist und gesagt hat, wo haben sie denn ihren Führerschein fälschen lassen, der ist ja ganz verkehrt. Der war einfach mal echt, aber die Geburtsdaten waren dieselben. Der Geburtsort war derselbe. Und wie gesagt, da müssten auch Unterschiede gemacht werden. Und da gibt es so viel Missbrauch, bzw. Missbrauch, der da gemacht werden kann, dem ganz einfach mal, sag mal im Erzlichen, wenn man gerade mal, na gut, wenn man im Koma ist, vielleicht nicht, aber vorher abfragen kann, sind sie das, benötigen sie das, haben sie das, ist okay. Ich meine, zu Ostseiten, muss ich sagen, haben wir auch gehabt, irgendwelche kranken Geschichten mit irgendwelchen Nummern. Deswegen mit dem 350 kb kein Problem.
Tilma, Entschuldige, worum geht es dir gerade eigentlich? Weil wir gucken uns jetzt gerade fragend an und fragen uns, was willst du?
Ja, es gibt zwei Probleme. Es gibt einmal das Positive, was man daraus ziehen kann, wenn auf dieser Chipkarte was gespeichert werden kann. Wenn da drauf die 350 kb gespeichert werden können.
32 kb.
Ja, dann können paar Zahlen auch gespeichert werden. Früher gab es mal, sag ich mal, zu Ortszeiten die berühmten Krankennummern. Und dann weiß man, was man hat.
Das Problem ist nicht die Chipkarte. Das Problem sind die Daten, die sich dahinter in einer Serverinfrastruktur ansammeln und wo wir gerade eben gesehen haben, dass in den offiziellen Sicherheitsanforderungen an das System. Ich habe mir gespart, jede dieser Sicherheitsanforderungen ist ganz klar auf das Sozialgesetz Buch 5 oder andere Gesetzestexte zurückgeführt wird. In der Regel Sozialgesetz Buch 5. Diese ganzen Dinge, die da als Sicherheitsanforderungen drinstehen, sind also in dem Gesundheitssystem Modernisierungsgesetz festgeschrieben. Und da ist festgeschrieben, dass die Krankenkassen in diesem zentralen System Auswertungen fahren können. Und da sind wir hingekommen, weil wir eigentlich mal die Frage beantworten wollten, warum hat man nicht einfach ein dezentrales System genommen, was viele Sicherheitsprobleme nicht hätte. Und wir haben an dieser Stelle eine Antwort. Wir reden hier nicht über irgendwelche Nummern, um irgendwelche Prozesse abzubilden, sondern wir reden hier über ein System, von dem politisch gewollt ist, dass es eine Auswertung gibt, bis runter auf die Ebene des einzelnen Bürgers. Und mit einem Verfahren, von dem in diesem Land zumindest mal ein großer Prozentsatz der Bevölkerung wusste, dass das ausreichend ist, Personen ausreichend eindeutig zu identifizieren.
Es geht aber auch darum, wie gesagt, um den gesellen Mensch und dieser geselle Mensch wäre im Prinzip das, um wieder Leute auszugrenzen. Und das kann doch einfach nicht sein, weil es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten für jeden Einzelnen, der im Prinzip in diesem Grenzbereich ist, der im Prinzip gar nicht sein hätte können, und es aber trotzdem machen und viel besser machen kann. Und das wäre doch im Prinzip, deswegen sag ich ja, ich sag mal für mich, eine Möglichkeit, diese kleinen Unheblichkeiten, die man hat, zu verstecken oder zu sagen, wir haben ja bloß das und das. Aber die Möglichkeit, daraus zu schließen, dass ich jetzt, sag ich mal, zuckerkrank bin oder sonst was, und die Leistung für die Arbeit nicht erbringe, ist doch im meisten Fall unrelevant, weil die Leistung wurde ja erbracht. Und das ist das Schlimme daran. Das ist im Prinzip die Politik des, na wie soll ich sagen, der Rachsucht mehr oder weniger.
Danke Tilma. Und wen wir noch haben, das ist Barbara. Barbara ist Apothekerin. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz interessant. Barbara, hallo. Wie ist denn die Gesundheitskarte jetzt mal von der anderen Seite des Tresens?
Also ich arbeite nur ausübsweise in einer öffentlichen Apotheke, aber das bringt mich auch gleich zu der Anmerkung. Also die Idee zu der Gesundheitskarte, so wurde es ja denke ich mal auch vermarktet, war der Lipobis-Skandal. Das ist schon mal ein Witz an sich, weil...
Der Lipobis-Skandal war dieser Blutdrucksenker, oder?
Nee, ein Blutfettsenker, der mit einem anderen Mittel, einer anderen Nutzstoffklasse kombiniert, zusammen zu Todeszellen geführt hat. Das war alles schon längst bevor das skandalisiert wurde bekannt. Die Ärzte waren informiert. Aber das war ja die grundsätzliche Idee, sollten eben diese Wechselwirkungen erfasst werden.
Es war vielleicht auch nur einer der glücklichen Anlässe.
Ja, es war ein Anlass, sich darüber mal Gedanken zu machen, ob das nicht klug wäre, auf Wechselwirkungen zu prüfen. Aber naturgemäß oder standesgemäß muss ich da mal als Apothekerin sagen, auf diese Idee sind der Apotheker schon länger gekommen. Und es gibt ein Modul in der Apotheken Software. Mittlerweile kann keine Apotheke mehr ohne Software Rezepte wahrarbeiten. Man muss für dieses Modul ein bisschen dazu bezahlen. Und das lässt immer ein Lämpchen aufblinken, wenn Wechselwirkungen erscheinen. Das setzt allerdings natürlich voraus, dass sich der Patient an eine Apotheke bindet. Also ständig seine Arzneimittel nur in eine Apotheke holt. Und seine Einwilligung gibt, dass diese Daten gespeichert werden. Aber wenn ich dann ein Rezept abscanne, die Medikamente abscanne, und ich sehe, das ist der Herr Müller, der ist im Hausapothekenmodell eingeschrieben, und der hat vor vier Wochen sich eine Thoma-Pyrin gekauft, und der kriegt jetzt Macumar, dann geht das rote Lämpchen an. Das ist das eine. Dieser Service ist im Prinzip schon längst und ohne Gesundheitskarte möglich.
Und ist natürlich auch in der Arztpraxis möglich, wenn der Patient bei einem Arzt ist, also wenn er sich einen Hausarzt nimmt.
Ja, das fängt dann wieder mit der Arztsoftware zusammen. Aber es hat auch seine Grenzen, inwieweit man Wechselwirkungen tatsächlich per Computerprogramm erfassen kann. Ich arbeite nebenher hauptberuflich eben nicht in einer Apotheke, sondern in einer Zimmer, die sich mit der Qualitätsforschung im Gesundheitswesen beschäftigt. Und von daher weiß ich, dass es für Ärzte eben auch immer ein Riesenproblem ist, diese Wechselwirkungen abchecken zu können. Was ist wirklich relevant? Und das sehe ich eben auch, wenn ich in der Apotheke bin. Dieses Lämmchen leuchtet nämlich fast immer. Man kann also nur unterscheiden, ist es nun Quitsch-Orange oder ist es jetzt Geld? Und man hat gar nicht die Keite, um was nachzuschufen. Es ist schon schwierig, dass der Computer nur die wichtigsten Wechselwirkungen raus, also wann ist es wirklich ganz kritisch. Das setzt natürlich auch voraus, dass man weiß, nimmt das Zeitgleich ein, aber da gibt's in dem Hausapothekenmodell wirklich eben prima Möglichkeiten, da die Dosierung einzutragen und so weiter und so fort. Also jedenfalls, es gibt Möglichkeiten, soweit es geht, diese Wechselwirkungen sich per Software anzeigen zu lassen. Und man muss dann eben immer nochmal mit demjenigen auch sprechen und ihn genauer kennen. Sowohl der Arzt als auch der Apotheker. Da braucht es diese Gesundheitskarte nicht zu. Das waren meine Anmerkungen erstmal in der Richtung. Also auch, was ich mir noch aufgeschrieben habe, hier mit dem USB-Stick, da ziehen wir gleich ein, ein Ärztennetz im Ried hat vor Jahren schon, irgendwann in den 90ern, einen Patientenbuch eingeführt. Ganz simpel, ein Patientenbuch. Und die haben prima Erfahrungen damit gemacht.
So was wie ein Impfausweis, oder?
Ja, hat der Patient selber gehabt, hat sich da selber eintragen lassen, was er für Medikamente bekommt und so. Ebenso ähnlich wie den USB-Stick, aber eben auch für Leute ohne Computer zu handeln. Also das wäre erstmal ein Ansatz, der wirklich praktikabel ist.
Ja, und man braucht sowas ja vor allem auch eigentlich nur bei Leuten mit chronischen Krankheiten, wo es eben auch eine nennenswerte Patientengeschichte oder Krankengeschichte gibt. Aber ich fand es schon mal sehr gut, dass du mir jetzt ja als Fachfrau auch einen Großteil der Argumente, die ich zu Anfang brachte, gegen diese automatisierte Rezeptprüfung eben nochmal bestätigst. Und so geht mir das laufend. Also ob Ärzte, ob Apotheker, die sagen, alle das Ding hat, von vorne bis hinten einfach schon medizinisch fachlich kein Hand und kein Fuß. Das sind irgendwelche Vorstellungen. So ein Klein-IT-Lad räumt sich die Welt zusammen, ohne mal real in ihr gelebt zu haben. Ja, wir leben fast in keinem Computerprogramm.
Dann frag ich aber, wenn sämtliche Ärzte mit denen du sprichst, und Apotheker mit denen du sprichst, sagen, eigentlich ist das der größte Mumpitz, den es nur gibt. Barbara, warum steht ihr alle nicht auf?
Na gut, man muss vielleicht dazu auch sagen, dass es...
Vielleicht hast du eine Theorie, warum nicht aufgestanden wird. Also es ist jetzt kein Vorwurf, also versteh mich bitte nicht. Also warum passiert nichts? Tausende von Ärzten und Apothekern wissen genau, dass es Schwachsinn ist. Warum passiert nichts? Das ist eine riesige, ich meine, das ist eine mächtige Lobby.
Sorry, Ärzte und Apotheker sind in erster Linie Freiberufler. Und ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch so unglaublich schwierig. Also die Ärzte sind sehr viel lauter in der Äußerung ihres Unbehagens, was man ja jetzt auch wieder merkt, sei es nun berechtigt oder nicht. Aber ich meine, wenn sie sich mal zusammenhaufen und schimpfen, dann hört man das aber auch. Das ist bei Apothekern, ich weiß auch nicht. Also die sägen noch selbst an dem Astach, in dem sie sitzen und denen ist es vielleicht lange Zeit zu gut gegangen. Und die versuchen es jetzt eben. Also es sind berufsständische Überlegungen. Und ich bin froh, dass ich mit dem Volk nicht allzu viel zu tun habe.
Ja, aber dieses Volk sollte so allmählich mal über eine Sache nachdenken. Ich habe das ja schon angesprochen, diese Idee, dass man die Nachtapotheken durch automatische Medikamentendispenser ersetzen kann. Und wenn das erst mal passiert ist, dann muss man sich natürlich sehr, sehr schnell die Frage stellen lassen, wofür brauchen wir dann am Tag noch einen Apotheker? Wozu brauchen wir überhaupt Apotheker? Das kann man doch alles mit solchen Paketstationsähnlichen Systemen...
Packstation, genau.
Ja, das ist jetzt die Medistation, die Apo-Station. Und wusch, einen Berufsstand weniger in diesem Land.
Na ja gut, wer erklärt den Leuten die Wechselwirkungen?
Wieso, das macht doch der Computer.
Genau.
Dass das nicht funktionieren kann, das...
Das wissen wir, ja.
Genau, das wissen wir.
Wir wissen das, aber die Planer dieses Projektes scheinen das nicht zu wissen.
Was, wenn sie es doch wissen?
Die Apotheker halten sich im Moment eben auch... Also haben sich insofern eben schon ein bisschen zusammengeschlossen gegen diese Konkurrenz aus den Versandapotheken. Also um ihren Berufsstand zu rechtfertigen, versuchen sie da jetzt schon einiges. Aber die Gefahr durch die Gesundheitskarte scheint irgendwie wirklich noch hinter dem Bewusstsein vorgedrungen zu sein.
Ja, ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass da Deutschland ein bisschen im Protest seitens der Mediziner und Apotheker hinterherhinkt, hinter dem, was in Österreich passiert ist. Ich hab das Gefühl, in Österreich, bei der E-Card, da ist eine unglaublich breite Front.
Ich sag mal, danke Barbara.
Ich hätte noch eine Frage zu der Datenlage mit den Krankenkassen. Ich hatte auch mal das Vergnügen, bei einer Krankenkasse zu sein und bin also aus ziemlich gut unterrichteten Kreisen dahingehend informiert worden, dass diese Daten ohnehin schon alle bei den Krankenkassen sind. Die persönlichen Daten, die zur versicherten Nummer gehören und die Verordnungsdaten. Und dass es den Krankenkassen eben einfach aus datenschutzrechtlichen Gründen nicht erlaubt ist, diese Daten zusammenzuführen. Inwiefern ändert sich das jetzt? Oder würde sich das durch die Gesundheitskarte ändern? Das ist mir nicht klar.
Also mein Informationsstand, der kann natürlich falsch sein, ist ein anderer nämlich, dass die Krankenkassen bisher die detaillierten Verordnungsdaten verbunden mit den Personendaten nicht haben. Und das würde sich jetzt ändern, weil sie haben dann die Verordnungsdaten pseudonymisiert, aber da sie ja die Personendaten haben, da in den Personendaten natürlich Geburtsdatum, Geschlecht und Postleitzahl, sei es nun vom Geburtsort oder aktuellen Wohnen auch drinstehen, können sie diese Verbindung jetzt herstellen? Und sicher, das wäre kriminell. Ja, aber Kriminelle zeichnen sich hier nun gerade durchaus, dass sie sich nicht an Gesetze halten.
Also diese Daten, man braucht sich zum Beispiel nur das Angebot der Techniker-Krankenkasse anzuschauen. Da kann der Versicherte seine Verordnungen sich ausdrucken lassen, sich ausgeben lassen. Er kann sich über beliebigen Zeitraum hin mit Anzeige des Datums, der abgegebenen Apotheke, des Preises, der Zuzahlung, kann er sich das alles anfordern, von der Techniker.
Also wäre mir jetzt nicht bekannt, ist eine sehr spannende neue Information. Müssen wir mal gucken, was wir dazu rauskriegen. Nur, wenn er in einem speziellen Modell drin ist oder jeder?
Jeder, der bei der TK versichert ist.
Ist es eine private oder eine gesetzliche Kassenkasse?
Gibt es da ein Stichwort zu, nach dem man suchen kann?
TK-VIA. V-I-A.
V-I-A, aha.
www.tk-online.de Und dann... also ich bin nicht in der Technik, aber... Von daher hatte ich schon ohnehin den Verdacht, dass die Krankenkassen diese Daten haben. Und das geht eben natürlich nur, wenn man als Versicherter selber eine Einwilligung gibt, dass sie diese Daten zusammenfügt.
Ah, das ist der Knackpunkt.
Das ist der entscheidende Unterschied. Diese Einwilligung wird es nicht mehr brauchen.
Richtig, das ist im Moment eine freiwillige Geschichte, wo du sozusagen selber deinen Datenschutz aufgeben kannst.
Ja, aber ich denke, dieser Datenschutz, der kann doch auch nicht durch die Gesundheitskarte aufgehoben werden.
Doch, weil da ist ja vom Gesetz her vorgeschrieben, dass diese Auswertungsmöglichkeit besteht. Und das E-Rezept, bei allen anderen Sachen wird die Zustimmung benötigt. Beim E-Rezept nicht, und das ist gesetzlich verordnet. Und da gibt es natürlich noch einen interessanten Hintergrund zu. Es wird im deutschen Gesundheitswesen der MorbierSA eingeführt. Das ist eine Kennziffer, die bestimmt im Prinzip das Krankheitsrisiko einer Person. Und die könnte man sicherlich ganz gut aus den Verordnungsdaten ausrechnen. Denn wenn ich die Verordnungen von jemandem kenne, so sagen es mir zumindest die Ärzte, und vielleicht bekomme ich hier noch mal die fachkundige Bestätigung live. Ich kann natürlich aus den Verordnungsdaten, in vielen Fällen zumindest, die Diagnose zurückrechnen. Zumal ja zukünftig auch die Therapiefreiheit eingeschränkt wird. Das heißt also, bei bestimmten Diagnosen eigentlich nur noch bestimmte Medikamentensets vergeben werden dürfen, also verordnet werden dürfen. Da wird das also technisch noch einfacher, das über sogenannte Expertensysteme zurückzurechnen. Und wenn ich jetzt auf diese Art und Weise die Krankengeschichte kenne, also das ist ja auch so ein bisschen, also im IT-Sicherheitsbereich sagen wir es ist eine Inferenz-Attacke. Ich leite aus anderen Daten etwas ab. Und dann kriege ich darüber die Krankengeschichte und kann mir meinen Morbi RSA auch ausrechnen und damit halt witzige Dinge tun. Das ist schon eine Änderung, denke ich.
Aber jetzt danke Barbara. Und bevor wir uns noch intensiver mit dem Morbi RSA beschäftigen, beschäftigen wir uns mit Österreich. Hallo Severin.
Was macht ihr in Deutschland schon wieder?
Wir machen alle Dummheiten nach.
Genau, wir machen alles nach, was die Österreicher macht.
Wie schlimm muss es eigentlich gehen, dass ihr ein österreichisches Konzept kompiert als deutsche?
Na ja, damit warten...
Also wir haben mal die Österreicher gesagt, dass Österreich, weil es so ein schön kleiner Markt sei, 8 Millionen Leute, aber ansonsten ganz gut repräsentativ für die EU, dass man sehr, sehr gerne so innovative Technikgeschichten...
Voll kollekt, ne?
Wie ist der Protest in Österreich, genau?
Die Icard, von der ihr ja schon länger gesprochen habt. Einmal wollte ich einen Zeitungsbericht zu Gehör bringen. Also keinen Zeitungsbericht, nur die Überschrift davon. Da stand nämlich dringend, dass der Verwaltungsgericht so viel festgestellt hat, dass die Kosten für die Icard jetzt um 13 Millionen höher sind, als man sich das eigentlich gedacht hat.
Schilling?
Ganz nebenbei. Ne, Euro.
Scheiße.
Ach, 13 Millionen, das sind ja Beträge, da können wir bei den deutschen Gesundheitskarten drüber grinsen.
Naja, das ist ein bisschen größerer Markt, aber ich mein, wenn du das umrechnest, dann glaubst du, du kommst wahrscheinlich auf den richtigen Tisch dahin.
Das zahlt Ulla Schmidt aus der Portokasse.
Vielleicht möchte Thomas ja mal irgendwie was zu den Kosten, zu den prognostizierten sagen.
Da können wir gerne was zu sagen, wenn du mit deinem Beitrag zu Ende bist. Also ich will dich nicht abwirken, sondern...
Nein, nein, ich nehme das auch nicht persönlich. Wir haben eine Gesundheitsministerin genauso wie ihr, die heißt Maria Rauch-Kallert. Kommt von der ÖVP, das ist so was wie bei eurer CDU. Und ist von daher noch ein bisschen schlimmer als Ulla Schmitz, obwohl ich ja langsam finde, die SPD könnte eigentlich geschlossen mit der CDU beitreten, wie das letztes Jahr so war.
Ich fände es lustiger, wenn es genau andersrum wäre. Einfach so aus...
Oh nein, oh nein, dann haben wir ja... Dann sagen ja alle, wir sind links damit und dann gibt es keine sozialistische Partei mehr.
Also da besteht eigentlich keine Gefahr. Man muss mal wirklich in der Wikipedia Ulla Schmidt politischen Werdegang sich anschauen.
Das mache ich gar nicht mehr. Das ist mir schon zu furchtbar.
Das ist aber in der Tat aufschlussreich.
Jedenfalls, diese Maria auch colored, hat uns jetzt vor einigen Jahren diese schöne E-Card angedreht. Wir leben damit jetzt auch sehr glücklich. Ja, also angefangen, das ist auch so lustig, angefangen hat das Ganze im Burgenjand, was an sich schon sehr lustig ist, weil das Burgenjand ist von den Witzen her gesehen so was ähnliches wie Ostfriesland in Deutschland. Also wenn du über gar nichts mehr lachen kannst, dann machst du Burgenjänder Witze. Und insofern hat sich das Gesundheitsministerium wahrscheinlich gedacht, bevor wir uns das anrechnen lassen müssen, wenn die E-Card nicht funktioniert, sagen wir, es waren die Burgenjänder. Und jetzt haben wir das da ausprobiert und nachdem das dann abgeschlossen war, ist unsere Gesundheitsministerin vor das Mikro getreten bei einer Adressekonferenz und hat uns erklärt, ja, es ist folgendermaßen, und zwar, also zuerst mal, wir machen das Projekt natürlich weiter. E-Card ist erfolgreich gewesen, nur es hat ein paar kleine Probleme gegeben. Hier und da sind ganze Computer abgestürzt, Arztpraxen konnten stundenlang nicht weitermachen und wie es vorher schon angedeutet wurde, standen die Menschen ein bisschen aus auf die Straße, das war zwar nicht aus Österreich, aber war ähnlich wie bei uns. Und man macht also weiter, obwohl man eigentlich gemerkt hat, was da schon alles schief gelaufen ist. Dann kam ein Rechnungshofbericht nach dem anderen. Und die Rechnungshofberichte, das haben wir auch schon gehört, haben immer höhere Kosten aufgezeigt und haben auch aufgezeigt, dass die eCard betrieben wird von dem sogenannten Hauptverband der Sozialversicherungsträger. Eine Organisation der größten Schnarchnasen, die ich jemals in Österreich überhaupt gesehen habe. Ich trau mich zu wetten, dass die Hälfte von denen ein UVB-Bateibuch hat, dass die Hälfte von denen schon mal mit dem Bundeskanzler und wahrscheinlich auch mit der Gesundheitsministerin Essen waren. Und die betreiben jetzt das, also sind natürlich ganz nebenbei auch noch, stehen sich sehr gut mit den Arbeitgebern, sodass man dann sich immer abspricht, naja, wie geht's in unserer Arbeit, können wir die nächstes Jahr noch behalten oder müssen wir die rausschmeißen? Oder können wir sie rausschmeißen, sagen wir es mal so? Und es gab eine parlamentarische Anfrage nach der anderen, die habe ich jetzt nicht alle rausgesucht, aber es waren sehr viele von der Sozialdemokratischen Partei und von den Grünen. Ähm, ähnlich waren die Reaktionen auf, nur kann ich mich eigentlich erinnern auf die Homepage des Finanzministers, die der sich von einer privaten Vereinigung hat finanzieren lassen. Also ich habe einen sehr guten Durchschnitt für zwei Jahre, die ich gehabt habe.
Vielleicht möchte ich an der Stelle noch anmerken für die, wie soll ich sagen, etwas basierteren unter den Hörern, die vielleicht auch schon mich aus anderen Chaosradiosendungen kennen. Ich hatte also auch eine richtig Auseinandersetzung mit der Betreibergesellschaft der österreichischen Gesundheitskarte. Ach, ja. Weil die nämlich in den Sina, nein, Entschuldigung. Ja, Wortspiel mit den GINA-Boxen, die Sina-Boxen sind in Deutschland. In den GINA-Boxen, das sind also diese kleinen Rechner, die in die Arztpraxen hineingestellt werden. Freie Software, die unter der GPL lizenziert wird, eingesetzt haben und sich nicht an die Lizenzbedingungen gehalten hatten.
Das heißt, ein Teil der 13 Millionen kommt daher, dass du die verklagt hast.
Danke schön.
Jetzt wissen wir wenigstens, wo viele Steuerzahler fragen müssen. Danke.
Wir holen uns das einfach von den Österreichern.
Aber wir sehen an dieser Stelle sind Rechtsbrecher am Werk.
Genau.
Ich hab mir gerade die Seite von Ulla Schmidt in der Wikipedia angeholt.
Da wird man sprachlos.
Ich bin das Daumen, das wir dich noch hören können, Holger.
Ja, ich war auch für einen kurzen Moment verstummt.
Ja, gut, kommen wir vielleicht zurück zum Thema. Ich würde sagen, wir machen mit den Kosten weiter.
Wir machen mit den Kosten weiter. Vielen Dank, Severin.
Danke. Tschau.
Die Kosten. Warte, ich lass eben sagen, wie die Sendung heißt. Der Sender war das jetzt auch.
Tschüss.
Am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wie immer, außer im Dezember das Chaosradio, heute Chaosradio 115, die Gesundheitskarte. Kritik an der, die Kosten der Gesundheitskarte, ich höre.
Ja, also die Kosten der Gesundheitskarte, das ist natürlich ein hochspannendes Thema, weil eigentlich kann man dazu nichts sagen, was ziemlich erstaunlich ist, denn es wird also immer gesagt, diese Karte wird also wahnsinnig viel Geld sparen und sie wird sich rasend schnell amortisieren. Dann stellt man so, wenn man ein bisschen mit IT-Projekten vertraut, ist natürlich eine Frage, wo ist die Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung? Und diese Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung existiert also augenscheinlich immer noch nicht. Die ist also irgendwann mal Mitte letzten Jahres in Auftrag gegeben worden.
Also wohlgemerkt, Jahre nachdem man das Projekt startet, beauftragt man die Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung.
Genau, weil es da schon eine gewisse Kritik gab, dass die nicht da war. Und die ist bis jetzt immer noch nicht fertig. Es hat mir mal ein Journalist erzählt, es soll angeblich eine geben, aber die hat keine Zahlen. Also es gibt Paralleluniversen. Ich bin davon immer mehr überzeugt. Dieses gesamte Gesundheitskartenprojekt bringt also massive Beweise für diese Paralleluniversen.
Ich stelle mir gerade eine Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung vor, wo keine Zahlen drinstehen. Das finde ich total klasse.
Der Nutzen ist einfach.
Der Nutzen kostet mehr, kostet weniger.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wir haben da einen ideellen Nutzen, der also gar nicht zu beziffern ist.
Ja, also diesen ideellen Nutzen.
Und kostet der jetzt mehr oder weniger?
Diesen ideellen Nutzen habe ich ja eben versucht, so ein bisschen dadurch auszuhebeln, dass wir mal so ein bisschen die fachliche, also die medizinische Nützlichkeit des Ganzen beleuchtet haben. Das sah ja schon nicht so gut aus. Das hätte ja so ein bisschen als Argument gegen diese Geiz-is-geil-Mentalität dienen können, dass man das muss ja nicht unbedingt was bringen. Vielleicht nehmen wir die Milliarden ja in die Hand, weil das medizinisch so nützlich ist. Ich glaube, das haben wir schon abgeräumt.
Gesellschaftlicher Fortschritt.
Kommen wir mal mit ein paar Zahlen. Also das ganze System muss etwa 80 Millionen versicherte Beherbergen. 180.000 Praxen von Ärzten und Zahnärzten, 21.000 Apotheken, 2.200 Krankenhäuser. Okay, die werden nicht alle die Ärztestreiks überleben, aber 260 Krankenkassen. Also ziemliche Zahlen. Und das Problem ist, es gibt keine Ausschreibung, es gibt keine Angebote, Kosten sind also nicht bekannt. Man hat aber durch die politische Vorfestlegung schon geschafft, dass die Industrie weiß, das Ding wird kommen. Also das ist etwa so, wie wenn man auf einen arabischen Bazar geht, bei irgendetwas in Verzückung ausbricht, laut schreit, das will ich haben und jetzt versucht zu handeln.
Über was anderes zu verhandeln, okay.
Und das hat auch schon von der Industrie zu öffentlichen Äußerungen geführt, also seitens Siemens, des Projektverantwortlichen bei Siemens, das in der Industrie Goldgräberstimmung herrsche. Ja und jetzt kommen wir mal zu den Schätzungen. Also wir haben auf jeden Fall einen Mietermarkt, wir haben eine schwache Verhandlungsposition, hohe Kostenrisiken. Die offizielle Schätzung für die Einsparung, da gibt es verschiedene. Es gab mal 1998 von Roland Berger und Pachtner und die wird immer wieder zitiert, eine Schätzung, man kann etwa eine halbe Milliarde Euro einsparen.
Wie die da drauf gekommen sind, haben die natürlich nie gesagt, oder?
Naja, also gibt es diese Studie, ich weiß nicht, ob sie öffentlich zugänglich ist. Es gibt eine andere Studie von den Kassenärztlichen Vereinigungen, die schätzen 200 Millionen Euro pro Jahr, und zwar im Wesentlichen aus dem E-Rezept.
Dass zwei Stunden Arbeit für die Ärzte bedeutet, das war das Ding von Anfang an.
Ja, das ist dann dieser Ersparnis, dass man das nicht mehr abtippen muss, wobei wir ja von der Apothekerin eben hörten, dass das heute gar nicht mehr abgetippt wird, sondern gescannt wird mit Optical Character Recognition wahrscheinlich.
Na, also wer will dann bitte einen von, also die Rezepte, die ich schon von Ärzten bekommen habe, die sind in einer Handschrift geschrieben, da versagt jede Optical Character Recognition.
Das ist richtig, aber wie viele hast du denn noch von der Hand geschrieben gesehen? Also ich sehe nicht oft welche, aber ich habe schon seit endlosen Zeiten kein Handgeschriebenes mehr gesehen. Die waren alle gedruckt und zwar alles in OCR-Schrift gedruckt im Übrigen, was ich gesehen habe. Und jetzt, dann gab es also so etwa bis zu meinem letzten Vortrag beim CCC zum Thema, also beim 22C3 gab es also immer die Schätzung aus dem Bundesgesundheitsministerium eine Milliarde Euro Einsparung. Das endete sich relativ kurz nach meinem Vortrag. Da waren es plötzlich zwei Milliarden.
Ja.
Ich finde das super, dass das Bundesgesundheitsministerium so schnell auch ist.
Ja, ist also ganz interessant.
Die Frage ist vor allem, auf welchen Zeitraum ist die Schätzung gerechnet? Sind das jährlich?
Jährlich, jährlich. Alles war alles jährlich. Ich meine, was ich interessant finde, ist, dass man in so einem Projekt noch solche Einsparpotentiale findet. Das ist für mich ein Zeichen, dass man also auch im Bundesgesundheitsministerium nutzen und wahrscheinlich auch Risiken des Projektes noch nicht verstanden hat, weil sonst würde man mal nicht schnell eben so bei kurzem Hingucken doch noch eine Milliarde Euro finden, die man jährlich spart.
Da arbeiten ja jetzt nicht wenige Leute im Bundesgesundheitsministerium. Hast du zu keinem Zeitpunkt mal Kontakt mit denen gehabt? Weil ich meine, du scheinst ja doch kompetent zu sein und wenn der, also weißt du, hat nie mal jemand mit dir gesprochen von denen? Also so, Mensch, du hast doch so ein bisschen Durchblick, sag doch mal, erzähl doch mal, ist das gut, was wir hier planen oder nicht?
Da kommen wir jetzt auf eine ganz komplizierte Geschichte.
Okay, dann lassen wir das.
Okay, lassen wir das.
Jetzt sitzen ganz viele Leute lächzend an ihren Geräten, denke ich.
Machen wir erst mal die Zahlen fertig, dann können wir vielleicht noch mal auf die komplizierte Geschichte zurückkommen. Also man muss sich erstmal überlegen, was das kostet in den Praxen. Die Schätzungen rangieren hier zwischen 1.500 Euro und 10.000 Euro pro Praxis pro Jahr. Nein, erst Investitionskosten, damit man überhaupt mitspielen kann. Das gilt allerdings, diese Zahlen gelten jetzt nur für die etwa 60 Prozent der Praxen, die schon eine moderne Ausstattung haben. Die anderen müssen überhaupt erst mal auf diesen Status investieren.
Die Landärzte beispielsweise.
Genau. Und wir haben auch noch nicht über Betriebskosten geredet. Die Betriebskosten liegen mal mindestens, also alleine nur für die Lizenz für dieses Software-System. Da haben wir noch nicht über PC-Wachtung geredet, über Virenchecker, über gar nichts haben wir da geredet. 745 Euro pro Jahr. Und das fällt nicht nur einmal an, sondern das fällt alle fünf Jahre an. Wieso? Ja, Ersatzinvestitionen. Ich meine, so ein PC hält ja nicht endlos. Die neue Software wird höhere Anforderungen an den PC stellen. Und das gilt für die gesamte Infrastruktur. Das wird für Server gelten. Das wird für die Chipkarten gelten. Die Chipkarten werden alle fünf Jahre ausgetauscht. Das ist so festgeschrieben. Also das haben wir alle fünf Jahre. Jetzt nehmen wir mal diese öffentliche Kalkulationsvorlage, die es auch von diesem Bit-for-Hells-Konsortium gab und was auch bei www.dimd.de steht. Und wenn man da die Zahlen, die ich eben genannt habe, einsetzt, dann kommt man also auf zwei Milliarden Erstinvestitionskosten, auf 1, 4 Milliarden Euro jährliche Betriebskosten. Ja, und jetzt das Einsparpotenzial, das kann man sich aussuchen. Auf jeden Fall Ersatzinvestition alle fünf Jahre. Und da habe ich dann mal auf Basis dieser Zahlen ausgerechnet, wo die Amortisationsgrenze ist und kam auf zwei Milliarden Euro pro Jahr. Und kurz danach waren die auch da. Leider, ich habe aber auch noch ein bisschen weiter gerechnet, da müssen die betreffenden Leute schon aus dem Saal gerannt sein. Leider hat die Videoüberwachung das aber nicht hergegeben. Also das ist wirklich Verbesserungsvorschlag fürs nächste Mal. Die Videoüberwachung muss also bei solchen Dingen auch hergeben, wer da aus dem Saal gelaufen ist, damit man die Verdächtigen kennt. Diese Kostenschätzung, bei dem die dazu finden, ist also sehr unvollständig, also meiner Meinung nach. Ich habe ja schon ein bisschen IT-Projekte gemacht. Da gibt es keine Posten für Gebäudekosten, keine Hardware, also keine PC-Wachtungskosten beispielsweise. Es gibt keine Firewalls. Also die sind vielleicht unter den 30.000 Euro verschiedenes. Gibt es Personal? Es gab kein RZ-Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, es gab auch kein RZ-Personal in den Rechnungen. Es gab auch keine Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen. Das muss alles in diesen 30.000 Euro verschiedenes drin stecken.
Das sind 1-Euro-Jobber, ich sag's dir. Arbeitslose New Economy, 1-Euro-Jobber.
Die zahlen wahrscheinlich drauf, damit sie im größten IT-Projekt der Welt mitarbeiten dürfen. Da wird immer gesagt, das größte IT-Projekt der Welt und das anspruchsvollste und so.
Zumindest im Pflichtenheft.
Man findet das ja ohnehin spannend, wenn man sich mal diese hochelektronifizierten Autos anschaut. Die haben alle laufend Pannen. Wir kriegen noch nicht einmal ein relativ harmloses Problem, wie hochelektronifizierte Autos hin, die einfach zuverlässig funktionieren. Aber wir wollen das gesamte Gesundheitswesen. Jetzt kommen wir aber noch zu anderen Zahlen. Also laut Kalkulationsvorlage soll die Gesundheitskarte 10 Euro kosten, je Karte. Die Hersteller sagen, da gibt es also öffentliche Zitate, wir kriegen die unter 15 bis 20 Euro nicht hergestellt.
Das sind 800 Millionen. Schlimmstenfalls.
Alle fünf Jahre.
Alle fünf Jahre. Dann in der Kalkulationsvorlage wird für je zwei Krankenhäuser Investitionskosten in Höhe von 140.000 Euro angenommen. In der Modellregion Trier wissen wir ziemlich genau, was die Krankenhäuser gekostet haben. Da hat es nämlich, also wir haben eine Untergrenze, da hat es vom Land offiziell einen Zuschuss in Höhe von 450.000 Euro für die zwei Krankenhäuser gegeben.
Pro Jahr?
Nein, einmalig jetzt. Aber da sieht man einfach, die Investitionskosten für ein Krankenhaus sind augenscheinlich viel höher. Es ist in Rheinland-Pfalz noch mehr zugeschossen worden, insgesamt 800.000, da wissen wir aber nicht im Detail was. Aber die 450.000 waren definitiv Investitionskostenzuschuss für die Krankenhäuser und zwar Zuschuss. Also die haben mindestens noch ihre Personalkosten selbst getragen. Wenn wir jetzt einfach nur diese Zahlen nehmen, dann kommen wir also schon auf mehr als 3, 2 Milliarden Euro Erstinstallation. Zu ähnlichen Zahlen kommt die Financial Times. Und es gibt eine Studie der privaten Krankenversicherer und der Kassenzahnenärztlichen Bundesvereinigung, die kommt auf über 4 Milliarden. In der Berliner Zeitung wird also von 5 Milliarden Euro Erstinstallationskosten erzählt. Und da ist dann eben auch dieser Dr. Günther Braun von Siemens, der in diese Goldgräberstimmung verfallen ist. Und damit steigt die Amortisationsgrenze natürlich nach oben. Und wir haben ja noch niedrig geschätzt, weil da immer noch, wir haben ja noch keine Gebäudekosten, noch nichts reingeschätzt.
Ich verstehe gerade richtig, also das Bundesgesundheitsministerium schätzt ungefähr 3 Milliarden Euro zu wenig.
Ja, so mal locker, ja.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwann in den nächsten paar Tagen 5 Milliarden Euro irgendwo stehen, dann können wir davon ausgehen, dass das Bundesgesundheitsministerium hier zugehört hat.
Ja, die Zahlen müssten sie schon früher gehört und gelesen haben. Ah, okay.
Schade, sonst hätte ich jetzt noch irgendeinen freundlichen Gruß an die Pfeifen vom...
Ja, also was ganz spannend ist, da haben wir noch ganz andere Sachen nicht berücksichtigt. Der Heilbronner-Modellversuch, da hat man die Kosten für die Arztpraxen etwas genauer im Überblick. Das sind aber keine offiziell zitierbaren Zahlen. Wenn man das dazu nimmt, dann wird es also noch mal ein paar Milliarden Euro teurer. Und dann gibt es noch eine ganz spannende Frage, nämlich das sind ja Signaturkarten. Und man hört immer wieder mal so ein bisschen Leuten, dass also jede dieser Signaturen Geld kosten sollen. So sagen wir mal 70 Cent. Wenn also ein Bürger seine Informationshoheit über die Daten, von der wir gesehen haben, dass er sie gar nicht hat, wenn er die also ausüben will, dann kostet das also je Vorgang, weil da muss er ja um eine Veränderung zu machen signieren, kostet das also viel leicht Geld. Es ist auch die Rede, weil den Ärzten die würden arm werden daran, da soll es billige Flatrates, Signier-Flatrates geben, von 20 Euro im Quartal. Also sollte sich mal jemand über die Praxisgebühr aufgeregt haben, ja, abregen, abregen, 20 Euro Flatrate signieren pro Quartal, ja.
Hatten wir noch irgendwie was vergessen in der Kostenaufstellung eigentlich?
Ach bestimmt tausend Dinge, aber ich denke, dass der Eindruck ist entstanden, den wir irgendwie versucht haben, irgendwie zu zeichnen. Wir haben also gesehen, dass wie so häufig bei Großprojekten irgendwie die Kosten immer höher geschätzt werden und dass die Nutzen irgendwie erstaunlicherweise auch also der Gewinn, den man sich verspricht irgendwie jedes Jahr, das Einsparungspotenzial auf magische Weise steigt, obwohl sozusagen die Anwendungen, die man damit ausführt, nicht steigen, sondern das eher im Gegenteil sinkt, bzw. bestimmte Dinge verschoben werden auf ferne Zukunft. Es ist also aus unserer Sicht doch sehr fraglich, wo denn der Gewinn auch allein auf der wirtschaftlichen Seite sein sollte, den wir da sehen.
Also Kosten nutzen sieht halt wahrscheinlich ganz fürchterlich aus, also Amortisierung ist unwahrscheinlich. Der medizinische Nutzen, haben wir ja so im ersten Teil ein bisschen gestriffen, wird wahrscheinlich die erhöhten Kosten nicht rechtfertigen.
Du hast eben gesprochen von einem MorbierSA. Was ist das?
Na gut, da bin ich jetzt nicht ganz der richtige Ansprechpartner. Das ist etwas, was auch mit diesem Gesundheitsmodernisierungsgesetz eingeführt wird. Es wird einfach eine Maßzahl dafür sein, wie viel Krankheitskosten jemand voraussichtlich erzeugen wird.
Herrgeleitet aus den kompletten Patientendaten, die dann irgendwo rumfliegen. Und was macht der dann, der MorbierSA? Also mein Risiko ist 70 Prozent. Oder die Kosten, die ich vermutlich...
Der erste Zweck, der damit verfolgt wird, ist Krankenkassen, die jetzt sozusagen eine besonders hohe MorbierSA-Summe haben, kriegen halt Ausgleichszahlungen von den anderen. Also es könnte erst mal interessant sein, hohes MorbierSA zu sammeln. Das heißt natürlich auch, es ist erst mal interessant, das kommen wir ja aus der Pflegeversicherung, es ist quasi interessant, die Leute möglichst hoch einzustufen, also möglichst krank darzustellen. Aber vor dem geschilderten Hintergrund, dass natürlich diese Daten ja auch benutzt werden könnten, um die Versicherungswürdigkeit oder die Anstellwürdigkeit von Menschen zu beurteilen, ist das eigentlich fast noch eine höhere Gefahr, weil die Krankenkassen ja erst mal ein Interesse daran haben, ihren Versicherten einen möglichst hohen MorbierSA zu verpassen, damit die Ausgleichszahlungen hoch sind. Wenn diese Daten dann später missbraucht werden, sind also die Versicherten auch noch extra krank dargestellt, weil das natürlich im Interesse der Krankenkasse ist, aber sie dann noch stärker negativ diskriminiert. Das ist so meine Horrorversion. Wenn diese Daten durch irgendeine größere Panne mal in größerer Menge freigesetzt werden, also nicht nur in Einzelfällen, was im Einzelfall ja schon dramatisch genug ist, aber wenn sie in größerer Menge freigesetzt werden, dann sehe ich halt wirklich die Gefahr, dass wir in eine Gesellschaft, in eine mehr Klassengesellschaft zerfallen. Also so Weißglas, Grünklas, Braunglas. Ja, so werden die Menschen sortiert und da ist natürlich klar, also das Braunglas, die mit dem ganz schlechten Gesundheitsrisiko, die darf man nicht mehr zum Weißglas dazugeben. Das sind die mit der ganz tollen Gesundheit, die kein Risiko haben, weil das weiß man doch nur, Braunglas verdirbt das Weißglas. Da kann man sich dann wirklich Horror-Szenarien ausdenken. Da schläft dann heute Nacht keiner mehr.
Jetzt ist es Gesetz, dass das eingeführt wird. Das heißt, es wird eingeführt, komme was wolle. Oder gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es eingeführt wird, komme was wolle. Möglicherweise haben wir ja mit der nächsten Bundestagswahl einen Regierungswechsel und da sitzen ein paar vernünftige Leute und sagen, alles Quatsch, wir nehmen das weg. Man kann ja mal träumen. Gibt es irgendwelche Gegenmaßnahmen? So ein System, keine Ahnung, so unbenutzbar machen können, dass es niemand mehr haben will oder wie wir es...
Schaffen die doch alle an.
Verdammt.
Also unbenutzbar ist es ja nach dem, was wir gehört haben, wahrscheinlich schon jetzt.
Na ja, wenn ich die Verschwörungstheorie ausspinde, dann geht es ja ausschließlich darum, die Daten zu sammeln, zentral zu speichern und auszuwerten. So, und das wird funktionieren. Alles andere wird nicht funktionieren, aber das Zentrale sammeln, speichern, auswerten und daraus dann irgendwelche Schlüsse ziehen, die nicht im Sinne des Bürgers oder der Bevölkerung sein können. Das wird passieren, so oder so.
Zumindest mal, dass das Missbrauchspotenzial besteht. Das kann schrecklich schiefgehen, die Geschichte. Und wir wissen, da haben wir aus unserer deutschen Geschichte genügend Beispiele. Man darf einfach solche Chancen, wo etwas so schrecklich schiefgehen kann, einfach nicht schaffen, weil das ist flirting with disaster. Und jetzt schief.
Unsere Regierung hat diese Chancen aber geschaffen.
Vielleicht möchtest du ja wirklich noch mal kurz das Anreißen mit der Volkszählung.
Ja gut, also Hintergrund ist, wir hatten ja in Deutschland durchaus schon mal eine Situation, wo auch in größerem Umfang Daten erfasst wurde. Das war also die Volkszählung 1936. Und was bei dieser Volkszählung eben neu war, ist, die wurde mit sogenannten Hollerit-Karten, also Lochkarten, durchgeführt und das erlaubte natürlich eine sehr schnelle Auswertung und auch eine sehr schnelle Selektion und da wurde eine kleine harmlose Frage gestellt. Religionszugehörigkeit. Und es ist unter Historikern durchaus wohl ein anerkannter Fakt, dass eben genau diese schnelle automatisierte Auswertbarkeit nach einem Merkmal, in diesem Fall eben Religionszugehörigkeit, Jude, eine der wichtigen Faktoren waren, der überhaupt einen so effizienten Holocaust ermöglicht hat. Das heißt also man sieht, dass die Technologie hier nicht nur eine quantitative, sondern eben auch eine qualitative Veränderung schaffen kann.
Okay, aber das hätte man beispielsweise unbrauchbar machen können, wenn man damals pfiffig genug gewesen hätte, dann hätte man einfach, weiß der Geier, Jädiritter reingeschrieben oder sowas. Oder alle hätten Katholiken geschrieben, weiß der Geier was oder alle hätten geschrieben, konfessionslos. Was muss ich bei der Gesundheitskarte, was mache ich da? Also wie hebele ich da das System aus?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Chance ist, aber eine Ergänzung noch vielleicht zu dem, also um das nochmal auf den Punkt zu bringen, was das Hauptkreditmerkmal ist, ist, dass hier zentralisierte Datenspeicherung über unterschiedlichste persönliche Daten eben erfolgt, die einfach nicht notwendig ist, in dem normalen Betrieb, wie im Moment das Gesundheitssystem funktioniert. Und dass also die zentrale Erfassung von jetzt irgendwelchen Krankheitsbildern oder was weiß ich, genetischen Dispositionen oder Ähnlichem ein enormes Missbrauchspotenzial erstmal birgt. Selbst wenn ich sage, ich vertraue der Regierung, ich vertraue den Krankenkassen und ich vertraue der Wirtschaft usw. Aber das kann vielleicht in 10, 15 Jahren oder so auch mal ganz anders sein. Je nachdem, wer die Daten in den Medien hält.
Ich meine, selbst unsere Kanzlerin hat gesagt, die freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung, glaube ich, darauf hat sie sich bezogen, ist nicht begottgegeben und von Dauer. Es ist nicht garantiert, dass es das in der Zukunft auch noch geben wird.
Genau, das ist das Problem.
Das ist ein Skandal, so was überhaupt nur zu sagen, aber sie hat nicht Unrecht damit. Das ist eben das Ding.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist halt etwas, was man realistisch sehen muss. Und wir reden hier von Daten, die wir, sagen wir mal, bei den Reisen ordnungsmäßig 100 bis 150 Jahre schützen müssten. Weil, sozusagen, wenn ich dann mal 70 bin, dann muss es noch zwei Generationen, also noch mal wenigstens 60 Jahre, halten, damit man aus meinen Daten keine Nachteile für meine Kinder und Kindeskinder ableiten kann. Damit sie ihren Wert verloren haben.
Das zu garantieren ist doch nicht möglich, oder?
Naja, also sagen wir mal, im Bereich der diplomatischen Daten, wo man eine Geheimhaltungsfrist von 70 Jahren ansetzt, sind die einschlägigen Behörden, sagen wir mal, nicht so extrem zuversichtlich, dass ihre Verfahren das halten. Und gehen da also mit sehr, sehr großem Geschütz dran.
Wir haben noch einen Anrufer. Wie geht's dir jetzt so nach zweieinhalb Stunden? Ich bin hellwach. Hast du von Anfang an zugehört? Ja, hab ich. Findest du das alles angenehm, was wir gehört haben?
Dadurch, dass ich so ziemlich noch überhaupt nichts wusste, finde ich es dann doch nicht ganz so angenehm.
Ja, mir geht es genauso. Ich weiß immer, dass ich ein Problem damit habe, wenn irgendjemand irgendwas über mich wissen will. Da frage ich mir, wozu überhaupt. Aber dass das so unangenehm würde, habe ich Eingangs der Sendung nicht erwartet.
Nee, ich wollte erst mal noch sagen, ihr hackt immer auf der Ulla Schmidt rum. Aber ihr glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft, dass jemand so dumm sein kann, so ein Projekt aufzusetzen, ohne sich dafür bezahlen zu lassen.
Das ist immer, die Alternativen sind eigentlich grenzenlose Dummheit oder grenzenlose Bestechlichkeit.
Aber grenzenlose Dummheit, also in dem Maße, traue ich selbst ihr nicht zu.
Ich kann es nicht beurteilen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde mich da auch mit persönlichen Anschuldigungen gegen Einzelpersonen, die man nicht kennt.
Ja, weil ich immer wieder gegen sie ziehe.
Ich meine es egal, ob gegen den Posten oder gegen die Person. Es geht einfach mal nur darum, dass sie als Einzelperson da bestimmt so dumm kann sie nicht sein.
Also ein vernünftiges, zumindest ein ihrerseits vernünftiges Verhalten müsste eigentlich sein, dass sie sich hinstellt in die Öffentlichkeit und sagt, das da, was wir da aushacken, das ist nicht gut.
Nö, das zeigt ihr ja eindeutig.
Was?
Das zeigt ihr ja eindeutig.
Nein, dass sie das macht. Also eigentlich, weil die Bundesgesundheitsministerin und Ulla Schmidt explizit stellt sich immer wieder hin und sagt, sie sei die Einzige, die Einzige, die im Grunde Lobbying im Sinne der Patienten betreibt. Alle anderen am Gesundheitsbetrieb Beteiligten würden ja nur auf die Kasse gucken und auf ihren Profit gucken. Und sie, hat sie kürzlich noch gesagt, sie wäre die Einzige, die auch tatsächlich im Namen der Patienten sprechen und handeln würde. Genau das macht sie ja nicht.
Ihr zeigt doch gerade, dass sie es eben nicht tut. Wenn sie es doch tut, dann wird sie schon ihre Gründe dafür haben. Und wenn sie privat liegen, dann, naja, ist die wohl Bestechlichkeit dann doch freundlich auszuschließen. Und der Lobbyismus.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht nicht unbedingt Bestechlichkeit, aber vielleicht gibt es irgendetwas, ich meine, man muss ja nicht unbedingt bestechlich sein, korrumpierbar zu sein. Richtig. Da wäre ich eben einfach vorsichtig. So doof, dass sie sich kaufen lässt, ist die auch wieder nicht. Weißt du, das ist eben das Ding. Weißt der Geier, was da wirklich die Gründe dafür sind, dass es so ist, wie es ist?
Ja, aber sie wird jedenfalls ihre Gründe haben, die sie auch privat hat und nicht...
Das sind Mutmaßungen, die bringen uns nicht weiter. Ich denke, das Einzige, was wir in dem Punkt festhalten können, ist schon, dass man es nicht von der Hand weisen kann, dass dieses Gesundheitskartenprojekt schon ein bisschen irgendwie ihr Lieblingsprojekt so war. Und dass sie das schon immer wieder gern herausgestellt hat, wie segensreich doch dieses Projekt sein soll. Und das ist eigentlich der Punkt, den ich jetzt rein sozusagen in ihrer Funktion angreide. Das hat nichts mit der Person zu tun, sondern es ist einfach, sich als Ministerin dahin zu stellen und zu sagen, das so zu fördern und so durchzusetzen, das Projekt. Das ist einfach der Punkt.
Ja, aber jeder vernünftige Mensch, dem man erzählt, dass das, was er sich ausgedacht hat, einfach nur dumm ist, im weitesten Sinne. Und das von vielen Seiten zu hören kriegt er, der merkt auch, dass es dumm ist und vertritt es nicht länger.
Vertritt es sich zu hören?
Ja, eben. Von vielen Seiten, die Seiten, die sie so umgeben, das sind ja gut, die Ärzte regen sich auf, aber die regen sich ja immer auf.
Die, die es betrifft, regen sich ja auf. Ja, aber die Frage ist doch wirklich, kriegt sie es von so vielen Seiten, die sie auch für vertrauenswürdig hält, zu hören. In der Art und Weise und in der Schlüssigkeit, wie wir das heute Abend hier gehört haben. Vielleicht ist sie, das ist ja auch was, vielleicht leben die. Ich meine, wie oft fällt mir alleine durch Zeitungslektüre auf, wie abgehoben von jeglicher gesellschaftlicher Realität selbst politisch nachrangiges Personal handelt, denkt und spricht.
Schön, dann können wir die Frage von vorhin ja gleich nochmal aufgreifen, die ihr so schick unter den Tisch kehren wolltet. Ja, warum meldet ihr euch denn da nicht? Oder habt ihr euch da gemeldet und euch mal beschwert?
Also, naja, wir haben sie nicht unter den Tisch gekehrt. Aber das wird natürlich ein sehr, sehr heikles Kapitel. Also, ja, ich muss einfach viel erzählen.
Es ist schlecht, wir haben Nachrichten in einer Minute.
In einer Minute haben wir Nachrichten.
Also, das sollten wir dann nach den Nachrichten verschieben. Aber es hat zwei Kontakte gegeben. Das eine ist, man hat natürlich versucht, mich juristisch mundtot zu machen. Das hat die Fraunhofer Gesellschaft versucht. In dem Gefolge hat mein Anwalt auch das Bundesgesundheitsministerium, da die durchaus zuständige Person, kontaktiert. Es hat nie eine Antwort gegeben. Und es hat auch einen persönlichen Kontakt mit einem Vertreter des Gesundheitsministeriums hier in Berlin gegeben. Anlässlich einer von einer politischen Partei angestoßenen Veranstaltung. Es sieht nicht so aus, als ob man da an dieser Form von Kritik interessiert wäre, um es vorsichtig zu sagen.
Und was sollte es dann in dem Fall bringen, wenn die Apothekerinnen auf die Straße gehen, wenn ihr sie dazu anfeuert?
Wir könnten ja mal testen, ob wir noch in der Demokratie leben.
Gute Frage, das wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Das ist ein wissenschaftlicher Test, den man mal fahren kann. Dazu brauchen wir aber entsprechend viele Leute, die entsprechend abstimmen. Jetzt sind, glaube ich, mal Nachrichten dran.
Danke für deinen Anruf.
Fußball, Fußball, Fußball.
Wenn ich jetzt noch einmal das Wort Fußball höre, dann ist hier aber was los.
Fritz bringt euch eine Veranstaltung mit ganz viel Hmhm und Musik. Fritz präsentiert den Perlekapp in Spremberg. Tagsüber mit einem Fußball... Tagsüber mit einem Hmhm-Turnier. Und ab 19 Uhr mit Clueso.
Die spielen doch nicht Etta.
Die spielen auf der Bühne. Spielt vorher das Fritz-Socker-Team. Und nachher legen die Fritz-Dj's Stefan Michme und Frankie Mansell auf. Der Perle Cup 2006. Veranstaltet vom offenen Jugendgriff des ASF. Kommen den Samstag in Spremberg.
Und im Radio Fritz von RBB 2, 5 1. Fritz Info Nachrichten mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
UNO-Generalsekretär Anan hat das Bedauern Israels über die Tötung von vier Blauhelmsoldaten im Süd-Libernone angenommen. Er habe dem israelischen Ministerpräsidenten Olmert eine gemeinsame Untersuchung vorgeschlagen, sagte Anan nach einem Telefonat mit Olmert. Bei dem Luftangriff im Libanon waren gestern Abend vier UN-Soldaten getötet worden. Die Kämpfe im Süd-Libernone und im Gaza-Streifen gingen ungeachtet der internationalen diplomatischen Bemühungen weiter. Ein israelischer General erklärte, die Offensive könne noch Wochen dauern. Bei Gefechten um den Ort Bin Jebeil wurden acht Soldaten getötet. Die Hezbollah feuerte mehr als 100 Raketen auf Nordisrael ab, mehrere Dutzende Menschen wurden verletzt. Im Zusammenhang mit der Korruptionsaffäre in der Autoindustrie hat der VW-Konzern Strafanzeige gestellt. Die Anzeige richte sich gegen alle Personen, die zum Nachteil der Volkswagen AG handeln, teilte der Konzern mit. Die Staatsanwaltschaften in Frankfurt und München verdächtigen den französischen Zulieferer Forcia, an Einkäufer bei VW, Audi und BMW jahrelang Schmiergelder gezahlt zu haben. Die Verhandlungen im Tarifstreit der kommunalen Klinikärzte sind nach fünfwöchiger Dauer festgefahren. Der Vorsitzende des Marburger Bundes Montgomery sagt in Ingolstadt, die Arbeitgeber seien weder bereit, ein neues Angebot vorzulegen, noch hätten sie sich auf eine Schlichtung eingelassen. Laut Marburger Bund haben gestern 15.000 Ärzte an kommunalen Krankenhäusern gestreikt. Zwei Fußball-Testspielergebnisse noch. NRG Cottbus hat gegen Atletico Madrid 1 zu 1 unentschieden gespielt. Hertha BSC hat wiederum bei St. Pauli 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Nacht bleibt trocken. Temperaturen sinken auf 20 bis 15 Grad. Tagsüber dann wieder Sonne, satt und maximal 36 Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz A10. Dreieck Schwanenberg Richtung, Dreieck Werder. Vorsicht bitte zwischen Dreieck Hafenland und Falkensee. Da hat es einen Unfall mit einem Lastwagen gegeben. Und das Ganze auch noch, wo die Autobahn eh nur zweispurig ist. Und A111, Autobahnzubringer Hamburg statt einwärts Richtung Charlottenburg. Sperrung zwischen Weidmannsluster Damm, Hermsdorfer Damm und Kurt Schumacher Damm. Wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten bis heute früh 5 Uhr. Ansonsten nichts Aktuelles. Gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Gerald, 4 Minuten nach halb eins.
Und wenn im Radio 91, 9, dann fritzt rund um Bellzig.
Chaosradio 115 mit der Gesundheitskarte als Thema.
Die besten Tage kommen, wenn du siehst, die Wünsche sind für dich und mich, elevate your soul.
Wenn du siehst, sind es für dich und mir.
Chaosradio 115, gerade als die Musik lief und die Mikrofone aus waren, hab ich eine meiner beliebten Boulevardesken Fragen gestellt. Angesichts der Tatsächlichen Erkenntnisse, die ich gewonnen habe im Laufe dieser Sendung. Wie gesagt, ich wusste von Anfang an, dass ich diese Gesundheitskartenidee vollkommen blöd finde. Warum das so ist, war mir gar nicht so klar. Angesichts der Erkenntnisse, die ich aus dieser Sendung gewonnen habe, stellt sich mir die Frage, ihr beiden, Harald und Thomas, ihr beschäftigt euch schon länger mit dem Thema. Was für Konsequenzen erwachsen für euch daraus? Aus diesem Wissen darum, dass da ganz offensichtlich, ich nenne es mal, verschwörerisch, dunkle Mächte am Werke sind, die vorhaben, diese Gesellschaft in einem Maße oder in einer Weise umzubauen, wie es der Gesellschaft selbst überhaupt nicht gut tun kann. Was für Konsequenzen erwartet ihr? Also, Auswandern, Attentat, Parteigründung, was tust du, Thomas?
Naja, also ich halte nichts von RAF-Vokabular.
Ja, klar.
Aber es ist schon für mich ein wichtiger Punkt, das klarzumachen. Also, ich habe eine andere Prämisse an der Stelle. Ich gehe nicht von dunklen Mächten aus. Ich gehe einfach tatsächlich von Dummheit aus. In der Mehrzahl. Also es gibt sicherlich, also ich habe inzwischen einige Erfahrungen gemacht, wo ich sagen muss, da gibt es sicherlich einige Leute, bei denen ich keine Dummheit mehr unterstellen kann, bei denen ich eher tatsächlich bösartige Absichten unterstelle. Aber ich gehe davon aus, in der großen Mehrzahl, sagen wir mal Dummheit, Unwissenheit. Dieses Gesundheitsmonetisierungsgesetz ist ja von den Abgeordneten beschlossen worden. Und ich habe schon von Abgeordneten gehört, dass denen jetzt erst mal so langsam dämmert, was sie da beschlossen haben. Also was das dann in Ausprägung tatsächlich werden kann oder heißt. Und insofern kann man natürlich argumentieren und Leute überzeugen. Und das mache ich jetzt seit, sagen wir mal anderthalb Jahren wirklich an der Öffentlichkeit. Das ist nicht immer einfach. Das ist harte Arbeit, hartes Brot. Man wird juristisch angeschossen. Es gibt gelegentlich mal Häufungen unerfreulicher, merkwürdiger Zufälle in meinem Leben.
Was? Wie unerfreuliche, merkwürdige Zufälle? Reifen plattgestochen oder so billig sind sie dann doch nicht.
Ölschraube offen und Bremsen verölt. Ja, ich meine, das kann ja zufällig passieren. Das kann ja auch eine Werkstatt vorher gewesen sein. Also wie gesagt, man kann da nichts nachweisen. Also das ist einfach nur eine Häufung von Zufällen. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Thema inzwischen und da kann ich mir also wirklich einiges anrechnen. Es war im Spiegel, es war in der Zeit, es war im Handelsblatt, es war im ZDF. Das ist das, was ich tue.
Harald?
Ja, für mich sind die Konsequenzen jetzt nicht so. Also ich bin ja auch niemand, der da jetzt sonderlich aufklärungsdurchstätig wäre, wie Thomas das ist. Ich hatte ja nur das Bedürfnis, das jetzt mal ins Chaosradio zu bringen. Aber es geht mir eben so, wie mit all den Themen zwischen Gesellschaft und Technologie, die wir so sehen, da kann man irgendwie die Ausweise, also die elektronischen, LFID, biometrischen Reisepässe sehen.
Die kann ich wenigstens noch in die Mikrowelle schmeißen.
Ja, und der bleibt sogar gültig, aber das hatten wir schon in einer anderen Sendung. Nein, ich sehe nicht, dass ich jetzt da groß insbesondere bei der Gesundheitskarte Handlungsimpulse oder Chancen oder Hoffnung oder sonst irgendwas sehe. Also für mich gibt es eigentlich nur die tägliche Menge an Zynismus und Bestätigung dafür, dass mein Bild von der kaputten Welt nicht so, also dass es einfach real ist. Also es gibt mir eine Bestätigung meiner, ja wie soll ich sagen, meiner Weltsicht. Aber mehr darüber hinaus passiert da eigentlich nicht. In dem speziellen Fall jetzt bei der Gesundheitskarte zumindest. Na, ich hätte gern mal noch so ein paar einzelne Punkte vielleicht, dass wir ein, zwei, drei oder so davon noch mit ansprechen können. Ein Punkt, der mir persönlich aufgefallen ist, ist ein technisches Detail eigentlich bei der Angelegenheit, ist, also es ist ja so, dass man da eine persönliche Geheimzahl hat, eine PIN-Nummer mit der Karte. Und jetzt gibt es bestimmte Vorgänge mit der Karte. Da muss der Patient selber seine PIN eingeben. Dann gibt es andere Vorgänge. Da muss der Patient und der Arzt sozusagen die Freischaltung mit Hilfe der PIN beziehungsweise dann des Heilberufsausweises auf Arztseite erfolgen. Und was mir dabei aufgefallen ist, nur so ganz oberflächlich ist, dass also die PIN-Eingabe bei der Gesundheitskarte nach den mir vorliegenden Informationen weniger stark geschützt ist als die PIN-Eingabe zum Beispiel beim elektronischen Online-Vanking mit HWCI-Karten. Also die Sicherheitsanforderungen...
Das war doch schon schlecht, oder? Das war doch schon nicht gut, oder?
Ja, da kann man darüber streiten. Aber man hat sich zumindest offensichtlich hier einen höheren Sicherheitslevel ausgedacht, wo man zertifizierte Lesegeräte verwendet mit eigener numerischen Eingabetastatur. Also so was wie Keyboard, Sniffer, Keyboardlogger schon mal gar nicht erst eingesetzt werden können. Zumindest jetzt nicht in dem Maße, wie das der Fall wäre, wenn man jetzt das über die Tastatur eingebt. Und wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, dass ich in Zukunft auf der PC-Tastatur eines Arzt-PCs meine persönliche Geheimzahl zur Gesundheitskarte eingebe und wenn ich gleichzeitig auch weiß von Kollegen aus dem IT-Business, die Systemadministration von Rechnernetzwerken in Arztpraxen und dergleichen machen, wie es da so üblicherweise aussieht, also im Sinne von wieviel Viren da so umeinander geistern. Nicht biologische. Ja, ja, eben. Also Computerviren. Also es sind halt Mediziner, das sind keine Fachleute für IT-Security. Und da wird kein besonderes Augenmerk darauf gelegt und da ist kein besonders hoher Sicherheitslevel an die Installation von jetzt im Netzwerk in so einer Art Praxis gegeben. Und wenn ich jetzt dann also an so einer Tastatur meine Geheimzahl eingeben soll, dann kann ich sie ja gleich irgendwie auf meine Homepage setzen.
Wobei das stimmt wahrscheinlich so nicht ganz. Zumindest ein Teil der Prototypen für diese Doppelchip-Kartenleser, die haben eingebaute Tastaturen. Nur das hilft natürlich auch nicht. Das ist ja der entscheidende Punkt. Denn die könnte man auf der Rückseite öffnen und die Tastatur ablesen. Die sind zwar versiegelt, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jeder Patient den Chip-Kartenleser immer umdreht und guckt, ob die Versiegelung noch in Ordnung ist. Man kennt ja nicht alle regulären Bautypen. Es kann ja jemand durchaus mal einen gefakten hinstellen. Dann hat er die Nummer und das nächste Mal kann er dann doppelt und dreifach abrechnen. Was aber viel, viel schlimmer ist, muss ich einfach nur mal überlegen, in einem Altenheim oder ein Krankenhaus, da werden die Patienten ihre PIN einfach damit der Arbeitsablauf nicht zusammenbrissen. Natürlich preisgeben müssen, das kann gar nicht anders sein. Wie will ich das in einem Altenheim machen, mit Plinden, mit Demenden, mit Leuten, die schwere motorische Störungen haben? Das kann nicht anders sein. Das Personal hat die PINs. Zum Beispiel. Oder es wird ja mehrere PINs geben. Man kann sie alle gleichsetzen, das heißt, sie werden auch alle gleichgesetzt werden. Auf diesen Shipkarten ist eine universelle Shipkarte, mit der man auch sogenannte qualifizierte elektronische Signaturen machen kann, die dann der Unterschrift gleichgestellt sind. Damit kann man Kühlschränke kaufen, Patientenverfügungen machen und vielleicht auch Testamente. Dann sagt man jemanden, der 40 Grad Fieber hat, gibt mir deine PIN. Nein, das war die falsche, gib mir die andere. Oder man sagt, Oma, gib mir deine PIN. Nein, das war die falsche, gib mir die andere. Dann hat man also die Signier PIN. Wie gesagt, das wird in Zukunft wahrscheinlich alles das gleiche sein. Dann hat man sie ohnehin sehr leicht. So, und dann ist die Frage, was ist denn bei jemandem Pflegebedürftigen eine Patientenverfügung wert? Also nehmen wir an, der Pflegebedürftige hat eine hohe Rente und es bleibt etwas übrig. Was ist dann eine Patientenverfügung wert, die Maximalversorgung fordert? Oder nehmen wir den umgekehrten Fall, der Pflegebedürftige kostet mehr, als er per Rente kostet, das heißt die Angehörigen müssen zuzahlen. Was ist da eine Pflege, eine Patientenverfügung wert, die die Einstellung von Pflegemaßnahmen festschreibt? Und die elektronische Gesundheitskarte gibt es explizit, gibt es also Quellen zu, explizit auch gerade dazu gedacht, elektronisch Patientenverfügungen zu verfassen und zu hinterlegen. Also da tun sich wirklich Abgründe auf.
Du beschreibst eine Welt, in der ich nicht leben möchte.
Ja, und das ist aber genau der Punkt, wo ich sage, letztlich die Gestalt der Gesellschaft, in der wir leben und die freiheitlichen Bürgerrechte einer demokratischen Gesellschaft. Das fällt nicht jeden Tag vom Himmel, da müssen wir jeden Tag für kämpfen. Das ist wie Zähneputzen. Das ist nicht spektakulär. Man ist kein Held, wenn man sich täglich die Zähne putzt. Man kann aber nicht aufhören, bloß weil man mal Carias an einem Zahn hatte. Man kann durchaus darüber diskutieren, dass unsere Gesellschaften im Nachgang des 11. September wahrscheinlich sogar ein paar Zähne gezogen haben. Auf jeden Fall ein paar ziemlich große Plumpen haben. Aber trotzdem können wir nicht aufhören mit dem Zähneputzen. Wir müssen weitermachen.
Die letzten Minuten von Chaosradio 115. Die Gesundheitskarte war unser Thema heute. Ein bisschen ist es noch unser Thema. Es haben ein paar Leute angerufen, haben gefragt, gibt es das irgendwo noch mal zum Nachlesen im Netz, insbesondere die Kostenaufstellung? Weil die Nutzenrechnung, die gibt es ja noch gar nicht.
Es ist so, dass ja weite Teile der Recherchen jetzt zu diesem Chaosradio sozusagen basieren auf dem letzten Vortrag von Thomas Maus auf dem Chaos Kongress im Dezember vergangenen Jahres. Das heißt, wer auf die CCC-Homepage geht und zwar unter events.ccc.de slash kongress slash 2005 oder sich dann eben durchs Menü dorthin klickt, da kann man dann sich ins Veranstaltungsprogramm hinein begeben und dort dann den Vortrag zur Gesundheitskarte auswählen und dort dann hat man die 90 Slides oder so, die entstanden sind für diesen Vortrag dort, der auch drei Stunden oder so.
Na, zwei Stunden, eine Stunde Diskussion.
Na ja, gut, das ist ungefähr Chaosradio, haben wir jetzt auch drei Stunden und da findet man also das, auch wenn man den Wikipedia-Eintrag zur elektronischen Gesundheitskarte sich anschaut, dann ist dort ganz unten, also ganz unten bei den Links und bei den Quellenangaben ist auch ein Verweis auf eben jene Dokumente von dem Vortrag mit drauf. Sollte also aufzufinden sein.
Wir haben eben gehört, Demokratie ist nicht selbstverständlich. Die meisten machen sehr wenig, die geben einmal bei Wahlen ihre Stimme ab und da dreht sich dann eins der nächsten Chaosradios auch drum. Weil da gibt es das nächste Problem, das auf uns zukommt.
Ja, das ist eigentlich schon da. Das Missbrauchspotenzial und das Problem ist schon da. Es geht um das bisher eigentlich immer nur im Ausland vermutete leidige Thema Wahlmaschinen, das wir also mittlerweile auch in Deutschland haben. Bei der letzten Bundestagswahl haben also eine nicht unerhebliche Zahl von deutschen Staatsbürgern bereits an Wahlmaschinen abgestimmt und da liegt auch so einiges im Argen unserer Meinung nach und ist wieder ein sehr schönes Thema am Schnittpunkt zwischen Gesellschaft und Technologie, dass eine Chaosradio Sendung wert ist. Wir bleiben gespannt.
Die werden wir uns dann auch anhören. Ob es die nächste ist, sehen wir, wissen wir noch nicht so genau, aber eine der nächsten wird es auf jeden Fall sein. Das nächste Chaosradio ist Chaosradio 116. Das gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im August. Das Chaosradio gibt es nämlich immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, nur nicht im Dezember, da ist nämlich der Kongress zwischen den Jahren gleichsam. Das war es, Chaosradio 115. Im Studio bei mir zu Gast waren Harald und Thomas. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart.
Keine.
Es geht weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf und alles Wissenswerte zum Chaosradio findet ihr wie immer unter chaosradio ccc.de. Wir danken für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Gute Nacht.